this is jocko podcast number 295 with
echo charles and me jocko willink good
evening echo good evening
on november
14 2001 the troops of general fahim khan
rolled into kabul and liberated the city
from five years of despotic rule by the
taliban
to win over the pashtuns in the south
and begin operations against the taliban
the coalition planned to insert two odas
near the city of kandahar
major donald bolduck was a member of
special operations command and control
element 52 which had tactical control of
the two odas bolduc explain the mission
quote
basically from november 2001 until
complete we were able to provide c2 and
conduct unconventional warfare in order
to advise and assist hamid karzai
and ghoul sharzai in organizing
anti-taliban forces which was what they
were called at the time and to conduct
combat operations against the taliban
and al qaeda forces end quote
bolduc
further described the key tasks that the
oda had to accomplish with their afghan
partners quote we were to secure
kandahar city develop a plan to
stabilize kandahar city and operate from
a secure base
and then concentrically improve that
security from kandahar city which was
considered the cultural and religious
center of gravity out to other provinces
in the south and then on order
exfiltrate the operational area
coalition leaders also understood that
they could not simply leave the area
once kandahar was out of the
taliban grip
but had to set conditions for the next
phase of the campaign
major bulldog
asserted that the end state for the odas
was the creation of a quote
stable safe and secure kandahar city
ready to transition to more formalized
humanitarian assistance
and nation building operations
and that right there is a excerpt from a
document
that was written by the
combat studies institute press
out of the us army school at fort
leavenworth kansas and the document is
called a different kind of war
the united states army
in operation enduring freedom from
october 2001 to september 2005.
and when you think about that
that segment that i opened up with
that's 14 november that's just over two
months after september 11 2001.
60 days and in that minimal amount of
time
america went from peace
and relative tranquility
to war and to chaos
and
men in the military who had been
planning another standard day at work
or preparing for another training
exercise
or maybe planning to take a billet where
they could go get some more time with
their family
suddenly
these men were at war
the opening piece i read mentioned major
don bolduc
he was obviously
one of those men
that shipped off to afghanistan
to begin trying to sort that place out
and that first appointment in 2001 was
just the beginning for him
over the following years he would deploy
to afghanistan
over and over and over again and also to
iraq and other parts of the world that
were
under threat
and that major would finish out his
career as a brigadier general
and it's an honor to have him here
tonight
to share some of his experiences and
lessons learned
general balduck
thank you for joining us well thank you
for having me it's an honor to be here
you know as i was reading that and just
saw that date of november 14th 2001 and
i was in the military at that time
but
to think of the radical transformation
that was about to take place and how
quickly we went from this
sort of peacetime military to a wartime
military and all that that entailed
that's that's a that's a heavy situation
let's do this let's rewind a little bit
and learn a little bit about you
where you came from
how you grew up
and uh sort of how you ended up in the
situation that you're in right now
sure so we're so let's start at the
beginning
so the beginning i was born in laconia
new hampshire i've been a resident of
the state of new hampshire for 59 years
and i'm 59 years old
i learned my work ethic on our family
farm in guilford new hampshire we had a
dairy farm
we had a
vegetable farm maple syrup
the farm has been in existence since
our family is the second owner of that
farm my grandfather bought it in 18 my
great-grandfather bought it in 1899
coming down from canada
and uh
my uh
my grandfather had 13 children and my
dad was
seven of the 13. um and uh
what us baldicks did was uh we worked
farm that's how we learned right we
we planted gardens chopped wood um
uh you know back in the day we'd uh in
the in the deep snow my brother and i
like
we had our harnesses and we would pull
the sleds and we would dump the
maple syrup into the uh into the
container now it's all done by
by gravity through
through plastic pipes right into the sap
house
before it was done by good old-fashioned
grandchildren right
you know
and so
i wouldn't trade that for anything it
got me tough in the winter tough in the
summer tough in the fall
i built more stone walls than i needed
to do so moving rocks from point a to
point b was never a problem i went to
catholic school and got my butt kicked
by by nuns on a regular basis
and so when i went to basic training in
1981 after high school
what are they going to do to me wake me
up early
yell at me
i don't know how many times my dad told
me i was about as useful as a snowball
in hell you know what i mean but he you
know he loved me right he was just
trying to prepare me for the world you
know it's not going to be easy out there
you got to use your head right what made
you enlist in the army
my grandfather on the baldic side had a
policy that all baltic males will serve
their country
and he didn't care if it was the
national guard reserve's active duty or
what service it was but you will serve
and if you don't serve you're not
welcome
and he never served because when he got
here he was too old um
he was too old for world war one um
but he uh nonetheless
my i had uncles that served world war ii
korea vietnam
every conflict the baltics have been in
since uh since world war ii right and we
didn't get here until 1899 and so my
grandfather had to establish
some some children and some
grandchildren before he could start
populating the
the u.s military
but when i when i went into the um
i went into my recruiter in the 11th
grade because i knew i had to do it so i
went in in 11th grade and at that time
they had the delayed entry program where
if you joined early
you got credit for that service plus
you went in as a mosquito wing private
you know instead of just a slick sleeve
private right which was like you know
five dollars more a month right and then
back then it was double your basic price
that's right back then it was 200 a
month so i was pretty happy right so it
was good uh
and
and you know before that though in high
school i joined the uh
police cadet program in um
laconia new hampshire and it's a funny
story how that started right i
i was um
in 10th grade and we were walking over
from high school
it was aft after school but before we
had to leave for a football game
and it was an away game and i was
walking over with a group of guys over
to the to the little store to pick up
some some chow for the bus right
and and i uh
there's this
coke can
set up perfectly right on the curb of
the road and i thought man i'm going to
go kick that so
i started talking about you know
five seconds left in the game blah blah
you know and i kicked that ball i kicked
that can
and it hit the side of a police cruiser
parked at the light
and so
i know him now sergeant biennaz
jumps out of that car and he is pissed
off and
everybody get on the ground so we're all
laying on the ground and he's like who
did it so i raised my hand i go i did it
sir
he puts me in the back of the cruiser
and
he's
yelling at the other kids and you know
my friends and they ran off and i'm
sitting in the cruiser and
he goes so
what'd you do that for and i explained
to him that what i was doing and he said
all right sounds like an accident to me
he goes have you ever heard of the
police cadet program
i go
no sir he goes well i think you'd be a
good kid for that program right because
you had enough balls to own up to it you
know and i said all right so i did it
and i got selected and i and i started
out and i really loved it so
in 1980
a year before i graduated from high
school i i
had the opportunity to go through the
the part-time police academy program
and so i did it and
i ended up getting qualified as a police
officer so when i went into my senior
year at 18 years old i was a qualified
police officer working for laconia
police department
and i did that for a year before i went
into um
into the army
and
went into the army from 81 to 84 and um
and were you active duty i was active
duty yeah okay
it's basically
a little bit like a break for you
because you're not out on the dairy farm
that's right it's a huge break
well it's a huge break because it's not
um you know you can imagine being a
police officer while you're in your
senior year high school mr popular
that's right mr popular every every
party that got busted up was my fault
you know i i
obviously had inside information that i
passed on to the police
and it doesn't work that way right i
mean we don't care about parties
but your neighbors do particularly when
it gets too loud right so they call
and i just couldn't get that point
across but nonetheless um
you know after serving as a police
officer and you know i mean
you know my my dad was a task master
right i mean he was a a strong good man
who is no longer with us but nonetheless
served 35 years as a
as a
city councilman and mayor for our city
school board
just a great pillar of the community in
addition to being a um
you know a guy that would uh would do
anything for anybody and so anyways i i
learned all that stuff but working on
the dairy farm
you know haying hangs the worst thing
you can do in the world right i mean i
hated haying season when july rolled
around i prayed for rain
because we could we didn't you couldn't
he can't hang in the rain
but it didn't happen right i had a guy
who was a new guy came to work for me
when i was at seal team
seven
and he was a hard-working kid up ready
to move sandbags fill sandbags move
steal around
dump ammo pick up ammo whatever i need
to do finally after a couple weeks and
i'm not too impressed you have to be a
really hard worker to impress me
and after a few weeks
i said to him i said hey man you're
because i he had kind of just shown up
in my platoon he didn't go through our
work up or anything he was a new guy
just showed up in iraq showed up in iraq
and he's working his ass off
and i look at him one day and i said
hey you're you're a hard worker where
are you from and he said i grew up in a
dairy farm in minnesota
and i said well i appreciate your hard
work he said sir i'll do whatever you
want me to do as long as it doesn't have
anything to do with cows
and he told me his schedule he was up at
four o'clock in the morning every day to
milk cows get get home in the afternoon
after wrestling practice milk cows and
it was i don't know what he had with 300
or 400 cows he had to milk
so the dairy farm seems to breed some
hard work yeah well you know after uh
practice whether it was baseball or
football or whatever it happened to be
my dad said i'll see you at the farm and
so i would
jog from the high school uh up up moral
street to the farm you know
and uh and did whatever he asked me to
do up on the farm right and so when i
got to basic training and met sergeant
mules my uh
my basic training um drill instructor
um
oh you want me to make my bed you want
me to do this you want me to do that
yeah
you know i was up before he threw the
trash can down the aisle right uh
because that's just the way it was
and um
and he you know he would say to me
baldic you don't sleep i go
and i'd say well uh drill sergeant i i
do sleep but i don't require much right
and
you know so yeah that kind of hard work
did it and then the discipline that the
nuns instilled in me i mean come on
right it's just sister lucille right i
mean
she sounds scary she is scary she was a
flaming redheaded uh nun that just
scared the hell out of me and um
and she got her pound of flesh out of me
uh but
were you an athlete in high school i was
yeah what sports did you yeah i played
uh football baseball and basketball
and i was told uh you're too small
to play football but by my sophomore
year i was i was starting on the varsity
team
too short to play basketball but i was a
starting guard on the basketball team
i was they told me i couldn't pitch
but i ended up being a pitcher because
my arms were too short and i wasn't tall
enough and i couldn't get a good stretch
off the mound but
you know so
uh
i think the farmer and me uh
you know
don't tell me i can't do something kind
of thing right because um
i'm going to try and prove you wrong
so anyways you know when you enlisted in
the army did you do it
did you plan on was it a career was it
reserves or was it active no it actually
uh it was active duty okay but my plan
was to um
you know pursue law enforcement
so when i was coming out of the army in
1984 i was a sergeant
and i was going to
rotc
green the gold program
not to go on active duty but it was
through the national guard
and they were going to pay for my
education and i was going to get my
commission through rotc the beauty part
about
prior services you don't have to do the
first two years of rotc because you've
got basic training in ait under your
belt
so you started your junior and senior
years right
and
i didn't uh i didn't anticipate making
it a career at all
i wanted to be
be in law enforcement but
i got called down to my company
commander's office and my first sergeant
was there first sergeant kingston and
and uh captain jeffrey l ames
was there and he i reported to him
position of attention and he said
sergeant baldick i know you're getting
out
but i want to talk to you about that
because i think you should stay in i
think you should re-enlist and i you
just came down on drill sergeant orders
and you should go be a drill sergeant
because what are your plans
and i s and so i just explained to him
what i explained to you and he said yeah
i
i just don't see you
being successful as an officer
he said you're enlisted material you're
you're a sergeant major in the making
you know he said i think you should stay
in and you should follow that track
because you're gonna have the most
success with that and again this little
light in the back of my head did you
just tell me i can't do something right
kind of thing and uh and my you know i
took his advice and i said thank you sir
very much but
i followed a different path
well sergeant uh first sergeant kingston
calls me out into his office he puts me
in the front lane and rest position and
he says you count loud
to 50.
and he gets down real close to my ear
and he goes hey listen he goes
you take
and you go to rotc
and then
when you get commissioned you find
wherever this captain is in the united
states army
and you take those bars and you put it
somewhere the sun doesn't shine
that's what he says to me
and i go yes for a sergeant
as i'm you know 22 first time 23.
and you know he's so he's like he's like
get up so i get up and he dismisses me
i am a first lieutenant in special
forces training at fort bragg north
carolina and who's the command sergeant
major of the 16th military police
brigade sergeant commander major
kingston
so here i am a first lieutenant
in sf training
and i called his office and i told him
who i was and i asked if i could come
over and have a meeting with him so they
they did that and i went over and i met
with him
and he was so happy to see me right he
goes have you found captain ames
and i go no and he goes you know he's a
lieutenant colonel now and i go no i
didn't know it i didn't i haven't
tracked his career
but anyways he um
he goes ah i remember that day that was
hilarious and he goes i'm glad you're
doing well you're in special forces
training goes that's really great right
and so we you know
um it's just uh
i didn't plan on going back on active
duty but i did well in rotc and i
qualified for an active you know regular
army commission
and i said you know what
this is 1988
and it is not looking good
for jobs out there right
so i said
ah i'll just go in the army and we'll
see how that goes and i really didn't
anticipate staying too long as an
officer you know fulfill my requirement
you know and you know perhaps get out
but
as time went on and
i went in special forces were were you
uh so what was your job as an officer
were you an infantry officer i was i got
commissioned into the chemical corps
which was another thing i was like what
the heck you know i graduated number one
from northeastern university liberty
battalion i was number one
and the the explanation i got is well
you know the quality has got to be
spread out across the army and it's
based on needs of the army so i was like
okay sounds like a good so what was it
chemical officer chemical officer
nuclear biological and chemical officer
but you know what
when i was looking to get out after my
requirement wow
that's a good opportunity big bucks
great opportunities i was like
wow
the good lord was smiling on me
because you know
i and i went to ranger school and i did
all those things that you're supposed to
do so when i showed up at the combat
arms units right i had
you know
i wasn't just a
support guy right you know okay this guy
prior enlisted ranger school graduate
you know airborne school you know the
whole nine yards
and so it just gave you more credibility
um and as an enlisted guy served in the
fourth id in the 82nd airborne so i had
that in my background
and so it was all good but um
but you know yeah chemical core you get
put on the battalion staff and you have
to do the
you know you get you get all the
you know nobody's really interested in
doing nuclear biological and chemical
training
yeah
so you get you know you get all the
um you know the interesting uh
assignments and i did those with a smile
on my face and the best of my ability
and then you know
i was the first chemical officer to make
it through special forces selection and
training
so did you at what point did you learn
about special forces
well i learned about special forces in
1968 when i watched the green beret
movie with my grandfather
and um
and so i was like oh wow john wayne the
green berets you know so it was always
something in the back of my mind and
then
i was in korea on my first lieutenant
assignment and um the green beret
recruiters showed up
and i went and i said i'm gonna do that
right
and so that's what i did where were you
in the first gulf war happened
uh i was in 10th special forces group
okay um
and um
so we did that there and then we rotated
over to provide comfort the humanitarian
assistance thing up in northern iraq
which was great experience with the
kurds
um
and um
yeah so
i mean god just kept opening up these
little doors for me to like you know
scoot through and
um
but before i knew it it was um
you know i was a major on my way to
commander general staff college and
halfway to retirement you know 20 years
and i had a few extra years because of
enlisted time so
i was like you know hey
if i make it to lieutenant colonel i'm
going to be doing pretty damn good so i
was pretty happy about that
so the so you went through special
forces in what year through through this
election uh i went through selection in
1992 february of 1992. was how was that
was it challenging for you did you enjoy
it was it what you expected it to be
yeah i expected a smoke show
and that's what i got
right and i really liked the
the special forces selection process
because
nobody said anything to you right all
your instructions were written up on a
board and you had to be conscientious
enough to check that board frequently
because they would do things like change
it right
and then try and catch you right not
paying attention
um and
it was athletic events you know um that
you had to do it was like right up my
alley right so it was like
uh yeah good quality smoke show nobody
yelled at you they sleep deprived you
and they gave you really good i called
it um
i called it building barney rubble
machines right because it was like oh
here's a trailer with only one tire and
here's some straps and here's some poles
and you know you got to move it 10
kilometers and you know they would set
up these tabs and you had to build like
so it was like on the farm like our farm
was like a osha nightmare
um
you know we really didn't believe it
yeah it was a huge safety hazard right
and so you know
uh you know coming up with a fix for for
the tractor or for the for the uh the
hay baler when it went down or something
like that was you know
it was always right there right and you
know my dad's like hey we don't have we
don't have time and we don't have the
money to go pay for this machine so
let's you know use some nylons and some
straps
and figure this out right and so that's
what sf training was about you know it
was like hey
you know here's a bunch of pieces of
equipment figure out how to get it 10
kilometers and good luck right and work
as a team
and support each other so
you know that's what farming is all
about and not one person makes that farm
run it's a collective team that's my
grandfather had 13 kids that's why he
has over you know 500 grandchildren
to make it work you bring everybody
together and you just make it work so
um that's what i liked about you know
special forces uh training
uh and i like the idea
that not everybody could make it right
that there was this huge attrition rate
and so
i thought that was cool too because
it was this it was a special thing right
that not everybody can get through
and only only a certain type of person
can get through it doesn't make you any
better than anybody else it just makes
you different right and that's what
america is about was there anything that
was hard for you or especially hard for
you
yeah anything that required
height because i'm short
at five foot seven so you know these
things that required height and then
keeping up with
guys with long legs on the ruck march i
would it was a ruck jog for me uh to
keep up
because these guys had just this
incredibly long
uh stride and it was like god bless
america
you know come on cut that stride in half
you know but you know they they move at
their pace and they can't they can't be
slacking because you know then the
instructor sees they're slacking for me
yeah i'll pick up a job right so that's
the way we did it
and you're married when you were going
through special forces training right
yes yeah yeah i got married uh as a
second lieutenant i met i met my wife
sharon in college
we were both in the rotc program
together
she was studying nursing and she was she
joined the army at 17 years old had to
get her mom's permission
she went into the medical field right
and down to fort sam houston did her
training and
uh she's a she's
she's as hard as woodpecker lips i
always like i always like to say um
you know source of pride for me is that
uh you know i married a woman that wore
combat boots
so that was always that was always a
cool thing but yeah she
she was great and um
you know
she and she understood the army and
understood what you were going through
and i always asked her right i said hey
i want to do this right you know
can i get your support uh
you know i mean it's not going to be
easy for the family um
and that's why
you know leading up to
2001 when we had 911 we were gone a lot
because during the clinton years where
he downsized the conventional forces a
lot of the engagement and stuff fell to
special ops right we had to go deploy on
all kinds of different things out there
so we were gone a lot
and
so when we were gone a lot after 2001
my wife just took it in stride right and
so when she started hearing people say
well you know
they're never home anymore and she would
she would be able to use her experience
to explain hey you know this is
this is what it's all about right and so
she was very very good inside the
inside the family readiness groups and
you know very very supportive
particularly during deployments and you
know when we had casualties and
she she had that frame of reference you
know and uh
she was always there we've been married
for over 32 years now and i have never
she's never ever faltered
even when i even you know even when i
wasn't a very good version of myself
because of post-traumatic stress and
traumatic brain injury and
and you know um
pain management issues and you know i
mean that negatively affected my
personal and professional life too right
you know
when when
before we get into that when you
are talking about the 90s so now you're
what's what special forces unit did you
check into when you got done with
special forces school fifth special
forces group fort campbell kentucky
and then you were doing lots of jsets
heading overseas building these
relationships filling some of the gaps
that were left by the downsizing
conventional forces
what was your what was your
did you do a platoon command did you do
a team did you do a company command like
what was your billets there so i was a
detachment commander oda 582 and third
battalion uh fifth group
um and were you guys doing like regular
deployments would you go on deployment
so yeah when i in the 90s when i was in
the seal teams we would go on a
six-month deployment maybe we'd go to
asia maybe go to southwest asia maybe
we'd go on a ship but you were doing a
work up and you were going on a long
deployment were you guys on a schedule
like that exactly like that exactly like
that but
with fifth group i went to one of two
places it was either eastern africa
normally kenya
or it was
in the middle east you know
uh and we had um
you know
kuwait uae oman
saudi arabia
jordan you know those places yeah
yeah we must have crossed paths at some
point along the way we had to we had to
log the dragon eggs
i did a bunch of shipboard deployments
in the 90s yeah and and one where i
wasn't on board [ __ ] but yeah we were
constantly pulling into all those places
and doing whatever kind of exercises
um just always always over there one of
the uh one of the interesting
deployments that we went on that i
thought was was
really really good to work on your trade
craft was um
jtf bravo
the drug interdiction
missions that we did on the southern
border
and we would
we would deploy for 120 days to the
southern border and
we worked from the texas border to the
new mexico border arizona and california
and we culminated in california in the
cleveland national forest
searching for marijuana fields
and
and getting
scared to death by booby traps right
because they they were everywhere uh and
and we would track somebody and then
we'd find out they're actually tracking
us you know so it was like
holy crap right
in america you know what i mean uh and
so but we would get into our spider
holes and we would
you know we would you know i mean we
would practice um
i remember giving my battalion commander
a briefing and i was saying hey
we're gonna
we're gonna be in these holes guys are
gonna be in the holes for uh 72 hours
and then we're gonna under the cover of
darkness rotate them out get them back
to the um
to our you know mission support site
get a debrief and then we're gonna send
them back to phoenix to recover in a
hotel right
clean all their kit and we we had this
whole process
and we're gonna be we we made our
spider holes and all our camouflage out
of uh pvc pipes and all that and stuff
right and we break it all down you put
it in your pack and then you set it all
up and you dig your hole and that's what
you're going to be in right and we we
even came up with you know different
exercises in the spike because they
couldn't get out of spider holes right
and so he goes so what are you going to
do with the
with the
uh human waste well we're gonna carry it
out with us
and he goes oh you're gonna carry it out
with you and i said yeah we're gonna
carry it out with us sir
and he goes
i'd like to see that
so
i delivered to him
a hefty bag
full of extra mint and pee
and i put it right on his desk and i
said there it is sir
and i'll never forget the look on his
face
the sergeant major command sergeant
major pulled me aside and he said that
was either
the most brilliant thing that you ever
did
as a detachment commander or the dumbest
thing
time will tell
yeah that's well that's good as soon as
you said i'd like to see that i said oh
he didn't oh yes he did he did see it
yeah
so uh yeah those are interesting i never
did those missions but i remember
platoons getting sent out to do them and
it's basically doing reconnaissance of
drug transport routes coming across the
border all across the southern border we
would wait we would radio it into the
police and they would do the
interdiction uh and it was just uh
it was just a it was just a great
mission because we knew we were doing
something for our country and then we
knew we were also
training the hell out of ourselves
with these these you know special
reconnaissance techniques that
um hey
if they see you they compromise you
you're done so i mean it was it was good
it wasn't real good
so where were you when september 11th
happened
oh i was the operations officer for 3rd
battalion or 2nd battalion 5th special
forces group
and we were
getting ready to go to jordan
for
what was
the largest
socks and you know special operations
command centcom
um
uh joint chiefs of staff missions they
basically took about five
joint chiefs of staff missions and
combined them all
we're going to be headquartered in
jordan and include uh egypt oman uae
kuwait
um
and it was all over that geographical
area we're going to be doing all kinds
of decentralized missions and stuff in
in these countries and
airborne operations and we had a we had
a ranger company with us and
it was it was awesome right we put this
all together first time they were ever
going to do something like that and i
really liked it because it was a
regional approach to solving problems
right instead of a country by country
focus so it was really great and i'm a
big
big believer in this you know regional
thing i think it works out better when
people get together and try and help
each other solve each other's problems
as opposed to just focusing on one
country at a time
but anyways i don't want to digress
so we were getting ready to go over for
that mission i'm sitting in my office
the day before we're getting ready to
deploy in 9 11 hits right and i go down
the hallway to my boss's office and i
put on the television i go sir check
this out
by the time i turn it on the second
plane hit hit
you know and i said
sir i think we're under attack
and i said it looks like they're going
to hit every single one of our national
elements of power
and
you know
then pentagon gets hit
and then the plane goes down in
pennsylvania
obviously headed probably towards the
capitol or wherever that was heading so
they you know they hit the economic uh
they just hit the military they're on
their way to the political you know i
mean holy crap
president of the united states canceled
every single exercise except for the
jordan exercise
because
it was so important to the king of
jordan to have this thing
to have this exercise because it was
he was the hub country right and so
we deployed and we did it and uh it was
shortened from 45 days to 30 days
and that's you know we went directly
from jordan to uzbekistan for mission
planning and then
uh and then into uh
into terran county afghanistan
so you complete this training operation
in jordan yeah which must have been
strange doing this freaking training
operation when you know that the world
is like a ticking time bomb right it was
it was we're watching the news all the
time and you know we're we're i'm i'm
actually
getting messages from higher
headquarters get ready you're gonna go
you're gonna leave so we're we got the
log guys and ops guys and everybody
planning to move us from
jordan to uzbekistan but at the same
time
we have
560 000 moving parts for this five
country
uh operation and people doing airborne
operations live fires you know cqb
you know i mean just all kinds of high
adventure training right
and you know we're doing
uh joint and combined airborne
operations so you got
picture this you got americans
jordanians and egyptians on the same
plane getting ready to jump out yeehaw
right because you know as far as i'm
concerned that's a you know
i mean we trained them but they not
necessarily following our training you
know
and the way some of them exited the
aircraft it was like holy crap are you
kidding me so it was like
uh you know i know a lot of the
sergeants are looking at me going you're
killing me sir you know i'm like okay i
hope not yeah we're not that's not the
intent right but uh
i'm like hey we got to do this right i
mean that's what it is and
they would they would make sure it was
great and it went off without a hitch
but so then from there you go to
uzbekistan uzbekistan and and now are
you guys getting you guys got the
tasking okay you're going to afghanistan
go to as go to uzbekistan to start
planning right because how many guys
uh it was it was let me see 15 of us
and and colonel fox had to pick them so
he picked them and 15 of us went off and
then he turned over the battalion to the
xo
and the exo stayed in place and
in jordan and then slow but surely he
would rotate
the teams
into uzbekistan as space opened up
so what you get to uzbekistan
i mean what's the damn
what's the atmosphere with the team how
much do you guys know about afghanistan
prior to this nothing
nothing
absolutely did you did you did you learn
a language as a special forces officer i
did i learned egyptian arabic okay now i
passed the language test
school egyptian quiz show
with the lowest score
of um that you could get on the defense
language aptitude battery test
apparently
god didn't give me the ability to learn
foreign languages
and i did i struggled through what
spanish in high school and college but i
struggled through it i got through it
anyways but nonetheless um
so the lowest score qualifies me for a
romantic language like french and
spanish and italian and what do they
send me to fifth special forces group
where the language is egyptian arabic
category four language and i'm like
really
you want me to fail is that it
but you know like anything else test
scores you know they mean something but
they don't test
um
they don't test your will to do your
best right so
i i ended up graduating with a two plus
two plus and and got language pay at 75
dollars a month
and um
and i was just you know i called two
plus two plus just being dangerous
enough to uh you know use a foreign
language you know it's like it's like
being a first level black belt in
martial arts right you're just dangerous
enough to get yourself hurt
but it looks cool right uh but
nonetheless it is what it is and i
i
yeah
i i did that but
egyptian arabic does you absolutely no
good
in
afghanistan with pashtu and urdu and
you know tajik and uzbek and you know
so uranus about uzbekistan you're coming
up with a plan
and and
who's giving you direction at this point
what are you guys getting for a mission
tasking are you getting clear directives
or is it more
hey go go start to put something
together so to the credit of our seniors
everything was moving so fast and
everything was coming out of the
pentagon and the national command
authority
so quickly so rapidly uh that you know
we weren't getting anything right and so
basically
we had
two teams and then a command and control
element
that had to be led by a lieutenant
colonel and that came directly from the
secretary of defense
so my so it's not even the standard way
that we would deploy into a theater of
operations so you got two teams
with a battalion commander and a very
small staff that were c-tuing now third
battalion had the north
second battalion
had the um south
and first battalion had you know the um
the kabul bagram area
um
and
so when we got there it was like all
right you got the south you got to go
link up with harmon karzai you got these
two teams one's going to come from the
south one's going to come from the north
can't figure it out so we did and i was
happy to figure it out because it was
good how did you guys get in
so we went
uh mh1
excuse me mc-130s
to jacobabad pakistan
and this this is really it's really
funny because we were told okay you're
going to get there
and you're going to go find the special
ops air force unit
and they're the ones that are going to
fly you in
to karen cow um afghanistan where you'll
link up with a group of afghans
and then they'll take you to harmon
karzai
so that so that was the plan that was
the plan that was the plan and where did
i find the air force guys in the mess
hall
because i looked all around jacoba bad
form right and my boss is like i go sir
let's go to the mess hall
good call and so there they were they
were in the mess hall and so
uh you know
and will they bring you up in like
pavlos or something yes yeah that's
exactly at mh-53s we
went right in we took fire going in uh
one of them was hit they still brought
us in we did a what i like to call a
controlled crash landing i mean it was a
hard landing we all
fell all over the place inside the damn
thing
we jump out
the one advantage we had was nice night
vision goggles we didn't know
where they were or who they were but i
had worked on i had worked on
one pashtun sentence
please
take us to harmon karzai
i worked on that over and over and over
again
and we land we hit the ground
dust everywhere
takes a few minutes for the dust to
settle we get into a v formation and the
plan that we had was
i go colonel fox i go sir uh we'll move
forward
once we see him we'll set in security
i'll walk forward with my rehearse
sentence
and
you know we'll go from there
you guys point your weapons i'm not
going to point my weapon at them but i'm
going to have it at the ready just in
case i need it
and i can see them they're all all these
ad there's about 10 afghans there and
they're all pointing their weapons out
at me and i'm walking up and i look at
them and i got these
ak-47s right in my face
and all i could come out with was harmon
karzai
that's the only thing i could say that
well-rehearsed sentence gone
gone
and uh they um
you know gave me the you know good good
to go and you know i called up the guys
we came up they put us in trucks
and 20 minutes later we were meeting
army karzai in a mud hut and then we
just started doing mud hut diplomacy so
what's mud hut diplomacy look like it
looks like a bunch of afghans sitting on
the ground with us in front of a map uh
and uh we're telling them you know what
we're seeing uh from our aircraft in the
sky and uh are they bad guys are they
good guys and then we're coming up with
intermediate
places on the ground to go to
and our first convoy that we did this
uh was a
disaster little did we know
that
they would all huddle
around karzai's vehicle because they
didn't want anything to happen to them
and we had karzai in the wrong spot so
we had motorcycles and toyota corollas
and pickup trucks we lost complete
control of this
convoy and then we stopped to pray
right in the middle of the operation
right is this really a safe place to
stop and pray but it didn't matter it's
time to pray we're going to pray so we
did that so what we did was
we figured out
on the next one that we would put
our guys up front for security and we
put karzai back there
and nobody would pass karzai's vehicle
so we maintain control
now if you turned around and looked at
that gaggle back there it was like oh
yeah mad max yeah really that's a great
way to uh to explain it and uh but it
worked and so that's what we did
uh and as we move forward we got
more and more village elders and tribal
elders into the meetings and then of
course you know people were talking
about security concern you know what if
someone comes in and just opens up and
sprays the place and i said well it's
a chance we have to take i mean it's
just part of the part of the part of the
operational environment yeah you can't
mitigate all risk you can't you do your
best but there's going to be some risks
that you're going to have to take to
achieve your mission and they weren't in
the mood for us to disarm them they
weren't in the mood for us to search
them they weren't in the mood for any of
that right we had to prove ourselves to
them and then they had to get
comfortable with us
and we just had to trust
you know karzai and trust me the cia
guys that were there with karzai were
just as nervous as we were just as
concerned as we were
because the last thing we wanted was was
karzai to uh to get hurt because he's on
the phone
with
all of the news outlets right
in the middle of a briefing we get a
call hey
you know
whatever his name is dan rather or
whomever wanted to talk to him right
and so he would take an interview right
there and then you had the bond
committee um that was meeting to figure
out you know the government and who's
going to be the interim prime minister
and of course karzai's at the top of the
list they want to talk to him so in the
middle of that they call up and they
want to talk to him about stuff and
you know he just and just sit there and
listen to it
he was really good
he was really good in those days
he did a really really good job
and i had a lot of hope right
but
yeah things get politicized and things
happen and you know the longer things
you know go on
uh he he just he just you know
i really
thought he did a great job um
particularly at the beginning there and
you know the way he managed risk and the
way he made decisions and
the way he handled and the respect that
he got um he was the right guy at the
time right
and um
and so
uh it was it was just uh very very
interesting to see that
and of course in
subsequent
deployments i had a personal
relationship with karzai
so i could leverage that
pretty easily as a result of that very
first rotation to explain something that
had
looked like
in kabul
had gone wrong
but there was a lot of things in between
where it happened and what was being
told and what was being put out by the
taliban that weren't true and i was able
to get communications to him to be able
to say hey
that's not the way it went down sir
please please understand that my heart's
in in the right place and he would
now now speaking of things going wrong
um weren't you involved in a um
in a fratricide incident where a bomb
was dropped on your on your location
can you brief us on that one yeah i
i blame myself for that what a day um
so
we were
at
um shao walikat
20 kilometers north of kandahar which
was our our operational objective we had
to take kandahar from the taliban
the
religious center of gravity it was more
important to take kandahar than it
really was to own kabul or herat or mes
you know major sharif
because of the significance of it and we
had one presidential mission
and that was to
determine whether the cloak of muhammad
in the mosque in
kandahar was still there because it was
a huge concern
in the in the muslim community all you
know all the way back to mecca right
with saudi arabia i mean this was a big
deal
and so
uh you know
uh
we
we were doing combat operations for
three days north of here i mean we had
to go through a pass and this pass that
high ground was a bridge it was a it was
a orchard
in front and it was very well defended
by the taliban and al qaeda and they
weren't given this ground up very easily
and we were doing
combat operations leading patrols
trying to disrupt them we were we were
engaging them with
you know
you know f-15s and so on so forth and um
it was going pretty you know it was
going real well and we were getting
people
that were switching sides you know
afghans would come and switch sides and
they were giving us great intel and
stuff which is always shocking for
americans to hear about people switching
sides and it's very common especially
in the arab culture and i know that
there's a i want to say this is an osama
bin laden quote that you know the the
people are going to bet on the winning
horse so basically if you're strong and
you're winning people like okay that's
who we're putting our money on and so
this is what you were seeing on the
ground was as the coalition grew and as
karzai got more people people are
looking around going he's got more
people and they it's almost like a mob
mentality of joining joining that team
oh absolutely absolutely and and it you
know required flexibility and
adaptability on our part and i know i
know colonel fox was just never real
comfortable with it all right don
where did all these people come from and
i said well sir they came they came from
overnight
and they came from over there and he
goes
these guys were fighting us and i go oh
yeah they were fighting us and now
they're with us and we got the um
we you know they're all vouched for
because you know oh this is my cousin
this is my brother this is my you know
and so hey all right and you know we got
the sergeant major telling us you know
it's okay and then we got
you know elvis going thank you very much
thank you very much you know so he you
know
and he goes in we're going to harm him
and give him bullets and everything and
i said well yes sir we are uh and
and he goes ah jesus
so he was never really quite comfortable
with it
and he goes
he goes you you're good with this and i
said hey sir i don't know if we have a
choice number one but yeah
i'm good with it you know i grew up in a
small town
in new hampshire and i can see the same
thing happening there you know
um people sitting on the fence you know
historically
we've seen that you know
where the passive people start joining
the people that are winning and you know
before that they're passive now they're
active and you know vice versa so
yeah i think i think we'll be okay right
and uh
it's all right
i'm coming for you though if you're
wrong and i said all right now
that's fair that's fair so anyways we um
we're doing this and it's about 8 30 in
the morning and we get some good intel
and you know we get with karzai and we
get a good decision from him and we
start
we start our operations up well we had a
very very good
process for
clearing our fires we had a great sts
guy on the ground
and we have absolutely no errors and we
we needed to build up our force
structure going into f going into
kandahar
so
we took this point
we took this point in time
to bring in some additional
augmentees right
and
it was about 24 hours before this had
happened so what we did
was we
um
we did a good transition with everybody
we had attack p come in and he did good
transition with the sts and learned all
the sops and everything like that and
rsds guy and the tacp had uh changed
over
so just so everyone knows these these
are the guys that
call for fire from the air that's what
we're talking about
the tacp and the sts these are
individuals that are trained that's what
they do
it's i mean obviously it's a really hard
job
one mistake can be deadly and that's
what they're focused on and it's great
to have those guys because that's what
they do for a living right and so you
had a transition taking place where
you're going from one guy that had been
with you now your your force is growing
you got some extra guys that are going
to be able to help out
but they're just showing up
so
they're not quite up to up to speed yet
that's correct that's correct and um
and so
they did their transition
we had got a mail in for the first time
so guys were you know
guys that weren't directly involved in
doing anything were opening up their
mail and you know
i had done a walk around our
our defensive area which was an old
soviet uh
mortar pit right up in the high ground
and i'd walked around and i had gone
down the hill
just got to the bottom of the hill
and this big explosion
right out of nowhere
and um
i don't know how much time it passed to
be honest with you but i picked myself
up off the ground i had
pieces of body parts stuff all over me
blood all over me i'm doing a quick
assessment of myself
i got a real bad injury with my leg
and
you know
dazed looking around and it is utter
mayhem
we got afghans down we got americans
down we got
rounds cooking off we got rpgs cooking
off it's going all over the place
i start walking around i start grabbing
our guys
we go down to where karzai was and we
made sure he was okay and he was with
his cia guys and they had secured him
and the guys that were with him securing
him
i asked them if they would go out and
recon a safe place to bring in
helicopters because i knew we were going
to have to cast a vac here
and out 200 meters we had casualties
right um it was it was a mess
all 20 of the u.s guys on the ground
were injured some way or another some
more than others
and
we had um
i designated a casualty control point
and i got with my comms guys and we had
to find some
uh we had to
kind of like um
take
com's equipment from you know
cannibalize it from other stuff to make
to reestablish communications with
higher headquarters
i found colonel fox and he was
he was dazed and confused uh just to the
point where he was just not coherent
about what was going on so made sure
that he was
taken care of
and
went up on the hill and we started
pulling bodies off right with all these
rounds cooking off and everything like
getting getting guys off the top of the
hill getting them down
and we knew we had
to get um complete accountability of
everybody
and
we did that and i was missing one right
and went back up on the hill
to where his position was and
that was ground zero of the impact of
the two thousand pound bomb from a
b-52 up 35 000 feet
and
i searched everywhere
i found his hat
and i took his hat and i started picking
up
bits and pieces and i put it inside the
hat and i put the hat inside a bag and i
parked it
and that's how he was identified
but there was nothing to send home
absolutely nothing to send him
and another one of our guys that was
killed was completely torn in half i
found him under a vehicle
his
chest was still heaving
his legs were over here his chest his
body was separated from it
and i start doing cpr on him
and someone finally grabs me on the
shoulder and goes sir
no
it's not gonna work he's torn in half
so anyways we get him in a in a body bag
and we
get him off there and then we had one
guy that was not going to make it
but was
still alive and we kept him alive and we
got him evact
when the
when we had coordinated the evac we got
a b team
special forces company and an oda to
come in to backfill
that came in from higher headquarters we
got all the guys out
and
then we started doing the
the after action and regrouping because
we still had this was 5 december
we still had to go
and take kandahar
so me
my assistant s3
the battalion commander and a como guy
despite our injuries we stayed on the
ground
in order to be able to coordinate the
push to canar
so we did that we regrouped we got as
many afghans out as we possibly could
that were injured
that wasn't something that
haier wanted to do but we talked him
into doing it because it was the right
thing to do so we got our afghan
partners evac out
we helped with the casualties for them
as well in the village and everybody
came out and and helped from the
different
areas around the village
and
we just said screw it we're gonna we're
gonna
hit that
we're gonna hit that bridge we're gonna
pass and
we're going to knock him out of there
and
we went through
nobody was there
right
this was 8 december and
we went right into kandahar and we took
kandahar and the after action on that
though
and i'd blame myself to this day
the transition between the sts and the
tacp was really good
but the tacp
had to change batteries
and and those old soft lamps that we use
to target designate
when you do that the grid resets to your
position
so before you send anything or confirm
anything with the
aircraft you've got to make sure that
that you have your grid system squared
away and
that was the mistake that was made
and
as i go over this in my mind over and
over and over again even to this day i
think to myself
i should have been there
to make sure that
that i should have gotten an in
person briefing from the tacp that
he knew all those procedures i should
have got that and i didn't get that
and
because i didn't get it
because of we're in combat and because
of all the things that you talked about
earlier
you know a mistake was made and
hey
i was in charge of those operations on
behalf of colonel fox that was my job
and i didn't do my job in my opinion to
the best of my ability and we had that
event occur
and
you know
well i learned a big lesson
and i'm sure a lot of people learned a
big lesson but at the end of the day um
it um you know there's a
and i think you talk about it and you
know in your in your book there extreme
ownership the fog of war right
and klauswitz and his explanation of the
fog of war and i mean it's all there
right and
you do what you can do
in some cases you can only do so much
there's a lot of things going on
but in retrospect it becomes
clearer and as you say you got to take
extreme ownership
right not only on those things that go
well but most importantly on those
things that don't go well
at what point did you realize it was a
friendly bomb
well
it wasn't until
i was talking to the tacp
who was seriously injured
and he was apologizing
and he said i sir i made a mistake i
don't think
that i
i cleared that grid
like i was supposed to do
and i said hey listen mistakes happen
these things happen
please
you need you need to
focus on keeping yourself i mean he was
seriously in you need to focus on
keeping yourself alive so you can get
home to your family
these things happen
don't blame yourself now i know to this
day because i've spoken to him quite a
bit you know the burden that he carries
but um at the end of the day
you know
fog of war mistakes happen it's a
leadership responsibility
but it wasn't until then that i realized
oh crap
we gotta we got a friendly fire and sit
in here
and
so
when the investigation team came down to
investigate
we were already in kandahar and
we were already set up but we had
already written our statements and you
know i had a pretty good packet form
knowing you know anticipating what was
going on
and i think you talked about that in
your book as well you know when the
friendly fire incident said okay
let's
we know a whole bunch of shit's going to
come raining down on us so let's get
ahead of the power curve and
let's make sure that we
find out what went on and we tell the
truth and we get the accurate assessment
of what went on and when we came down
and
and it was uh
brigadier general burford
he was the
deputy commander for u.s special
operations command
he's one that came down and led the
investigation and sat down with his team
we said this is what we got
we got him out to the spot so he could
see it
and you know we gave him we gave him a
you know a good briefing on on that and
what we were doing and how we were doing
it and
we had taken that soft lamb and we had
isolated it um it had been damaged uh
but nonetheless wasn't being used
anymore and so we had everything for him
in a nice package and and i go hey
listen this is a combat environment you
know we don't want them we don't want to
have them come down here and have to
expose themselves to danger here while
they're doing their investigation but at
the same time we want to make sure they
get to where they need to go to do a
thorough investigation
and and the most important thing is
lessons learned so this
never ever happens again right
and i tell you what nine more rotations
never happened to me again
never happened in the unit that i served
in again
because we made sure
that
that you know those kind of lessons were
applied and
over and over and over again right yeah
when i took over the training for the
west coast seal teams like the tactical
pre-deployment training i would put
those guys in positions all the time and
they would every single group every
single platoon every single troop every
single task unit
they'd get a blue on blue
and i'd sit down and say i want this to
happen here so you realize how it
happened so it doesn't happen overseas
like it did to me
so that's the best thing you can do is
take those lessons learned and and
spread the word so it doesn't happen
again and i i can tell you that there's
still
there's still guys on that oda there's
there's all three
of the guys that we lost
still blame us still blame the chain of
command for that
right
and that's okay
i take that responsibility
fully i accept it and
um
i understand where they're coming from
and
that's just
that's uh hopefully it has
made me a
better leader right
as a result
i mean what else am i going to do right
except acknowledge it
and
you know move forward because my
responsibilities
in leading didn't end
as a result of that
yeah yeah and i mean even
to those those guys that were lost and
god rest their souls but at least
their the lessons that were learned from
that
horrible as they may be at least there's
you know as you said
no operation that you oversaw after that
ever had another incident so
their sacrifice saved lives and i know
that's
horrible in one way but it's the truth
it's also the truth it's also the truth
and um yeah i didn't never had another
blue on blue incident uh and the
as battalion commander as the siege soda
faith commander and as a general officer
level commander in afghanistan in combat
never ever had another one
and
you know we attribute that to of course
the experience of the guys as we go
through uh but most importantly
you know
leadership and learning they're
indispensable right
and so you gotta you gotta move forward
and that's what we did
so
so you guys roll into kandahar and it's
pretty much no factor
like
what was the resistance level rolling
into kandahar the resistance level
was minimal we got ambushed going in
and you know we took care of that uh and
we kept going
we get to
uh the mullah omar's compound
and
it is
uh
there are
vehicles everywhere
covered with mud
because that's what they did to try and
hide from our
aerial observations right they covered
their vehicles with mud they saw a
predator right so we
we
said and that was a way for us to
identify if they were if they were bad
guys or good guys because the bad guys
were covering their cars
but here it is again i looked at you i
looked at colonel fox and i said hey sir
look
a parking lot full of bad guys
and now they're on our side right and he
goes i don't get this
and then we went to the jail and we
brought john muhammad
now john muhammad was a very very close
friend to karzai and he had been
imprisoned by the taliban and tortured
for a very very long time
and he became the governor of uruzgan
and he got up there and he met with
karzai
and this is a guy that i developed a
very good friendship with over the years
no matter what job i had
going back into afghanistan in his mind
i was
the commander of all special forces
right
i just was not and i would tell him i go
hey listen i'm just the battalion
commander here i just got these guys he
goes oh no no you are the commander of
all special forces
and he would tell people that and it
would get in the news right and and i'd
get a phone call and i go i didn't tell
him that right
and so he probably knew he was getting
in trouble
he's like ah commander of all special
well he was
he was a wild man always had been a wild
man and if there's one guy that you
wanted in because orson province was you
know i mean it was full of taliban it
was full al qaeda and we needed a guy
like that to go up there and you know
a clean house but the way he was
cleaning house and the way that you know
it was acceptable in the international
community was two different things
and so
we had to keep a very close eye on that
but nonetheless
um he
gets there
and he goes all right i'm going to need
some furniture so he starts going in the
rooms and he starts going i want that i
want that i want that
and he goes into moolah omar's office
and i wasn't with him but one of the
guys was in there and he comes running
over to me he goes sir you got to get
over here
he goes
the guy that we just let out of jail
he's going to the bathroom on top of
mula omar's desk
and i go what
and i go in there and he left
a mess on top of that desk
and that was his
just what he felt he needed to do
and then he told karzai i'm on my way to
orozcon province when i get the taren
cut i'll let you go i'll let you know
and
we'll start clearing that place out
and uh you know karzai put governors in
oregon province it's a bull province for
our province
nimrou's province hellman province
hellman was the
one that we got the largest number of
taliban al qaeda
and operational russian equipment out of
um and we had to negotiate that right we
had to negotiate that with the taliban
leader there that you know he wouldn't
you know he'd be free to go off and do
whatever he wanted to do and you know
karzai said yeah i don't care
and uh
sharzai was the um
governor of kandahar now
the governor of kandahar is the senior
governor in the south that's just how it
works
wields a lot of power even though you
have governors in all the other
provinces so he pretty much laid down
the law
and you know organized things
and slow but surely you know we started
seeing security in southern afghanistan
just
you know shape up and then and how long
did you stay in afghanistan for
uh for that first rotation from november
to march and then
uh
the so you left in march of 2002 right
had the governor's been put in position
yet oh yeah they were all political
positions so that's december yeah so at
that point there's a pretty good
it looks that's looking pretty good at
this point it looks real good it looks
real good they're doing it the afghan
way
and
the airfield in kandahar was something
that
we wanted to secure
uh so that we could you know use it to
bring in and bring out you know supplies
and stuff like that
so general mattis
one star general at the time
the marines got that mission
and so um
their
operational area was was really confined
to
kandahar airfield and then we had
the siege sodas north
up in uzbekistan
and then
then commodore harwood came in to do
senior sort of south
kandahar
and he worked side by side with
with general mattis
and
we were in kandahar
and our sole advise and assist
responsibilities
um
centered around cher's eye at this time
because karzai had gone up to take to be
the interim prime minister
up in kabul
and so
everything that we did we did through
with and by
um
karzai or shirzai
in coordination with siege sort of north
who were ctoing us and then
commodore harwood who was ctoing um
a separate direct action unit out of
kandahar out of the kandahar airfield
and we got this task list
from from syphilic right the combined
forces anyways it was a three-star
headquarters right
and so uh it was about 180 different
places they wanted to go to
and
that was our
tasking to to go do that we had to get
that done so would you say go to what do
you mean go to like like they thought
they thought it was places that had
intel or had bad guys in it and all
under 180 of them were dry holes like
towns or villages or like actual target
packages targets right without the
target packages it was just a location
and we think there's something there uh
but the places that
all 180 of them were dry holes but the
places that we got all the computers and
all the stuff that
uh that
osama bin laden was working on and omar
was working on were given to us by the
afghans that were on the ground hey they
worked out of that one they worked out
of that one they worked out of this one
and and we would get a call saying hey
we got
al qaeda there see that's where it
became tricky because taliban were
afghans
so you get them
and
they either switched sides or they
didn't switch sides right if they didn't
switch sides well
um you know the
the
you know afghans you know would would
deal with them through afghan law right
and custom whatever
al qaeda different story they were arabs
and
we had to be very very careful
because there was only one fate for them
if they got in the hands of the afghans
who had been
families had been
killed and tortured and so on and so
forth and they didn't have any real love
for them right so
that was a
whenever we got a report in saying
uh as al qaeda
suspected al qaeda guy we would go boom
and we would take we would take them
into what i would call protective
custard
right and then we would move them by our
own means
to
be interrogated
and
by you know coalition side of the house
right
and so i mean that's that's uh the kind
of difference between the taliban and al
qaeda at the time
there on the ground and how they were
just you know dealt with
differently and
we didn't really worry about the afghans
because they always switched sides but
it was the
it was the elk it was the al-qaeda
because they were from oman they were
from saudi arabia they were from
pakistan they were from some other place
right
and not welcome no they were not welcome
and you know
one of the worst places to go when we
first got there was
the soccer field because that's where
all the hangings
the beheadings
and the stoning of women took place i
mean stoning women for and killing a
children for flying a kite
we handed out thousands of kites when we
got down there
because they're huge kite flying folks
they have competitions you know where
they attack each other with the kites
you know it's just like this huge thing
anyways um they loved it right
we got them their music we got them
things to play with their music we
established businesses one of the
one of the first businesses that we
established was a woman's um laundry
and then we used it to clean our own
stuff because by the time we strategic
thinking right there by the time we got
to kandahar we stumped right
i mean it was pretty bad so anyways we
we did that but
i'll never forget i was on it was four
four o'clock in the morning
i was up on the kandahar um governor's
mansion and i was doing my had my uh
night vision goggles and i got my afghan
partner with me and to keep them awake
all you had to do was give them the
goggles because it was like
this was amazing to them right it was
amazing to see that technology and they
could see because they'd go
and then he'd go back down right and i
know you can't see me on the radio but i
mean it it you know it's just is what it
is but
i'm up there and i see
the bakery that we had established them
you know
and the guy goes in for work and he gets
in there and he starts opening up and
that's where we got our bread every
morning and that nan bread that
football shaped bread it was warm it was
delicious by that time we were getting
peanut butter and jelly sent to us and
my wife sent me a tub of marshmallow
because i'm from new hampshire
fluff and nutters are really good right
peanut butter and marshmallow sandwiches
so i was looking forward to it but i'm
watching this guy and i go there he is
you know
doing his thing we
he starts
you know he gets the dough all done and
he gets in the bowl
with his feet
and starts needing it
and i'm like no
i did not just see that right you can't
unsee no and i'm like
and i know what his feet look like right
and i'm thinking to myself it's done
i i can't eat bread again
right
and we go get the bread and i'm sitting
down and battalion commander's sitting
there and
watching the guys and i go all right
guys i gotta tell
you i got to tell you this is what i saw
today
i gotta share this with you i hope i
don't ruin it for anybody
morally obligated to share this
i gotta share it with them and i did and
they looked at me and they go i don't
give a [ __ ]
i'm eating this bread and he goes the
brick oven burned it all off and i go
i can't get there
i can't get there right so it kind of
ruined it for me but anyways
that's good
so by by the time you leave for the
first time in march
you know it looked like things are going
pretty
as good as you could want them to go
when do you get back there again
so you know it was interesting
i get selected to be the fifth special
forces group
s3 so i get bumped up from the battalion
go up to the group level
and
we're now of course
sustaining
operations
uh well it had gone to a different group
so we didn't have to worry about
afghanistan anymore at fifth group
because we're not really there
so because it was third group but then
we got the warning order for
iraq so we start planning iraq
and then i get called in to
my group commander's office
he says hey
you just got by name requested to go do
an interview to be the secretary of the
army's aide
oh joy i go sir i just got the job that
i've always wanted
group s3 i mean
it doesn't get any better than that in a
sp in a special forces group right and
in my mind anyways
and i was like sir i don't i don't want
to do that he goes well you don't have a
choice and he goes and you better not
blow it
because we need an sf guy at that level
it's never happened before so we need
you there right we need you there so you
go there and you do the best you can if
you don't get picked don't worry about
it but don't sabotage it
so i go there and tom white is the
secretary and i do my interview and um
i'm sitting at home and i get a call
it's tom white
don
you're gonna be my aide
you got two weeks to get here
and i go holy crap so
i call my boss and i tell him and he
goes yeah congratulations it's great
it's going to be great for the sf
community blah blah
it's funny because the entire time i was
an aide there i never got a call from
the sf community
not once
but i did what i was told to do and i
went there and i was the aide for tom
white and what a great experience that
was right how long did you do it for
what a great one year that's all you get
right uh and then you move on and then
uh so
that's what what year was that that you
were the eight 2000 june of 2002 to june
of 2003. got it right
and then
i went
what did you before you jump into where
you went next what did you you know you
said it was a great experience i was
fortunate enough
you know as fortunate as you can get
when you become an aide i was fortunate
enough to be the aide for for the seal
admiral admiral mcguire and definitely i
loved him
he's a great guy great guy but i was
very lucky that i was able to do that
job because i got to see a lot and
got to understand what was happening and
understand how these high level
decisions were made and see a little bit
into the future what was it from from
your experience what did you see that
what did you learn that was important
well
all of what you just learned but
more importantly i learned
um how all the just you know how these
decisions are made inside the the
political level right um from the top
and all these things that are done
so when i got back to the tactical level
i could explain to the guys what's going
on at the strategic level and although
although they may not like it at least
i had a familiarity and an understanding
and be able to explain to them what's
going on in the whole process and why
we're sitting here you know waiting to
be ordered to go do something or what
what have you uh but i learned how the
army worked
they didn't know how the army worked
right and a lot of us go through
hell there's a lot of guys that get
promoted to general officer and they
don't even know how the army works right
because they've never been in a job that
taught them how the army works it's just
a matter of so
you know there i am you know i'm you
know i'm the you know battle buddy of
the secretary of the army you know
and he depends on me for everything
right and um
and it was just a phenomenal opportunity
to learn how the army works and how the
army fits into the larger
service and how the joint chiefs of
staff works and you know
how all these things go and and uh so
um you know
i did not want to leave the the group s3
job at all i just you know i didn't want
to and when i got asked the question
by secretary white you know do you want
to be
do you want this job
and my answer was sir i'll be honored to
serve as as an aide
but
i'd rather be this fifth special forces
group s3 jack
and i was told later that's why i got
the job because everybody else they
interviewed wanted to be they
and i didn't so they gave it to the guy
that didn't want it yeah yeah
and um
and i went there and i gave him 110 like
i would do any job if they made me the
floor sweeper it'd be the best damn
swept for foreign army right that's just
the way it goes right you just go do
whatever job they give you and do it
best of your ability and then you know
you know good things will happen and so
i did that and then i
went over to
i got picked up for lieutenant colonel
and i got picked up for battalion
command first battalion third group
and i had to do some joint time so i
went over and i worked for i was the
executive officer for the assistant
secretary of defense for special
operations low intensity conflict
so then i got to see how the osd worked
right
and how all of that went and i always
like to say how it works and doesn't
work right because there's both sides of
the coin right but it is good excellent
experience and i met some really great
people there
that i
have relationships with to this day
but
um
that was
three
june of 2003
uh and then i went and took command of
fifth special forces group um first
battalion third special forces group the
desert eagles and we did two
back-to-back tours to afghanistan there
and
[Music]
that was
that was awesome
one of the only battalions that ever did
back-to-back tours it's just the way it
worked out so we went there for nine
months
came back for six went back for another
nine months
um and then i went up to
use the sock headquarters the the amount
of continuity that's one thing that when
you compare let's say world war ii with
either the end of korean war or the
vietnam war where you have guys coming
on tour they're gonna do a year and then
they're gonna leave and that's that's
that
um
that's almost a continuity
when you do nine months there six months
home and then nine months back there you
start to get some real continuity
what what did you see in that deployment
uh or those two deployments you get to
see like a bigger arc of the story yes
with with a better thread through it so
we really saw the um
the uh reemergence and the resurgence of
the taliban and al qaeda
in 2005 when we got there may of 2005 is
when we got there now now
obviously 2003 i think i might have cut
you off when you were about to say this
before but 2003 things are looking
about as good as we could hope in
afghanistan the war kicks off in iraq
that means
people are you know american soldiers
resources are now pouring into iraq that
sort of becomes the focus
and and that allows over in afghanistan
where we had a big presence now all of a
sudden that's drawn down now all of a
sudden
the you know al qaeda and the taliban
start to see opportunities yes and so
when you roll back in it's now 2005
and now they've taken advantage of some
of these opportunities they have taken
advantage of the opportunities yeah and
i'll never forget
september 11 2005.
i was on a hilltop
with charlie company commander
and
in the um
kandahar
province
and
there
were 1500
wave after wave
of taliban fighters
coming at us
it was unbelievable
september 11th 2005 that was that was
i had been you know i mean 2011
uh i mean uh september 11th 2001 wasn't
that long ago right and you're right i
mean we had it looked good in 2002
2003 and four
we
didn't have the resources that we needed
but we were still doing
nation building we were still building
an army we're still building the police
we were putting together their
justice system we were putting together
their constitution so on so forth all
that was working
but there wasn't anybody to keep the
pressure on them right and so
they researched and so we saw the brunt
of that in kandahar province in
in 2000
2005 september 11
operation medusa
um
and uh
you know it was a big operation
um
and
uh it was just
it was just unbelievable what was going
on during that time frame in terms of
you know enemy capability capacity
strength numbers
and it wasn't just
southern afghanistan which is where my
battalion was it was in the north it was
in the east
you know predominantly at that time in
the east we were on the border right wow
that was just incredible right
so what's going on all over the place
right you know when you when you talked
earlier you mentioned that you know we
were helping them we were writing their
constitution we were setting up their
government we and there's a
you know when i when i talk about
leadership a lot um which i do
i talk about what happens when you try
and impose your plan on to your
subordinates onto your team you impose
your plan onto them look
you can kind of get away with it
sometimes depending on the authority
that you have depending on the amount of
leadership capital that you have
depending on how much oversight you're
allowed to kind of sit there and if
you're going to impose their plan a plan
on them and then you have the tenacity
and the
and the ability to sort of
continue to put the pressure on them
then maybe
maybe you can pull it off but it's much
better from a leadership perspective to
say
hey don you know here's this mission
how do you want to do it and kind of let
you come up with a plan
it seems like america has a tendency to
want to impose
you know our way onto countries whether
it's vietnamese there's the the the
vietnam thing the way that unfolded and
the way we tried to sort of impose
what we wanted it to look like
and the vietnamese
don't like that
they they've fought against that forever
and they've never been beaten and so
they weren't going to be beaten and and
it wasn't that they didn't like what we
were saying it's just that they wanted
to say what they wanted to say
so so you know here we are with the
afghans so doing a little bit doing some
imposition on them
and and the way that turns out it's sort
of like from a leadership perspective if
you don't have the the constant pressure
to say no no this is exactly what i want
you to do and i have the the tenacity
and the leadership capital the resources
to kind of make you do it which again
this isn't ideal
how do you think we find ourselves in a
situation where we
we seem to make that that seems to be
our tendency to want to impose our
our way our plan on to other on to other
people
well to your point i mean it just it
doesn't work out well right and and the
way we had set it up there was the us
was doing the military
the germans were doing the police
the italians were doing
the justice system
and then there was this collective body
that was writing the constitution
and we factored out one of the most
important things that goes in a
constitution or a or a document whatever
they choose to call it
that establishes their their government
and how their government is going to
govern
in a muslim country and that is they
don't separate church and state right
and that was one of the big mistakes of
that document right
and then
we named the government um for them as
well which you know they didn't like
either so one once they got it turned
over to them they made you know karzai
went in they made they made the changes
right
and we were building a top-down western
government uh police and military force
which isn't
culturally the way they do things right
it's very decentralized very
decentralized and we're trying to
centralize it and we're trying to
centralize it from kabul down and they
don't do that either you know their
political system is very democratic to
begin with it's
it's shures and jergers and it's local
and it's consent among the tribal elders
and the village elders which are
which are different right because you
have the tribal elders and they may not
be the elected village elders right but
they still work together and they
understand and then they have a pecking
order of
the tribes
and so when stuff goes when stuff is
available the tribes get their fair
share
based off of where they sit in the
pecking order and they're okay with this
but we don't like that a lot of times
right
because we want the
the minority one to get the stuff but
they're okay with the stuff they get
because
it's good enough right
so
we went in and we mucked all that up
right because we we're just not familiar
with the tribes
idealistic about the way we think things
are going to be i remember
a very similar example we had these
young iraqi soldiers
and the the officers were skimming their
paychecks
and you know my guys come to me they're
you gotta they're skimming the paychecks
of these young enlisted guys
so i started talking to my interpreters
and i go hey wait what's going on can
you help us you know i want to
understand what's happening he's like
well of course they are
the soldiers know that that's that's
that's their boss and he's going to take
a little piece that's the way it works
that's that's fine
so
us going and trying to impose what we
have this ideal of the way things should
be doesn't always match up culturally
and it turns into a problem yes
and that's exactly what you know i mean
the same thing happened in afghanistan
right and we were obligated to fix it
which puts us in a position
we don't have any real authority to fix
right
not going to listen to us they're still
going to skim it they're still going to
do their thing they'll just figure out a
different way to do it
and although we see that that is bad i'm
not saying it's good i'm saying it's
just the way it is right and
over time these things will change like
we saw
in afghanistan right now
the ambassador to the united states and
afghanistan is a woman
never would have been that way in 2001
or five or ten but in 20 it's a woman
that's great that's progress
they'll figure it out right they have a
great university system that they
figured out you know it's one of the
things we really didn't get involved in
and it works
right
and i don't mean that that everything we
did was terrible because obviously it
wasn't but
when you start getting involved in a
country's institutions and you start
getting involved in their culture and
their society and you're an outsider
it's never going to be received well and
you're probably going to you know
trample over something that you should
just you know just stay away from but
the good things will happen
as
they
you know continue to move forward and
another thing
that a lot of people in the villages
they didn't want
to go from the 7th century to the 21st
century right they didn't want to they
were very happy being in the 7th century
you know one of the things that i would
always tell folks that
would come to you know to do
humanitarian work in afghanistan i say
don't give them coats don't give them
shoes they don't want that
all they're going to do they're going to
smile at you they're going to say thank
you so much they'll even have kids
running around with this stuff on but as
soon as you leave
the kids are taking it off putting on
their sandals
they wear sandals you know even in the
wintertime right they're not going to
put on winter boots they're just not
going to do it but they're going to take
those winter boots and they're going to
put them on trucks and they're going to
go to pakistan and they're going to sell
them and then they're going to come back
home
because they don't have any use for them
what they have used for is paper and
pencils and school products and things
along those lines that they that they
will use and they won't go sell because
they want their kids to be able to draw
they want their kids to be able to write
they want them to be able to you know so
stop giving them converse sneakers
you know it's they're not going know you
know they're not gonna wear them you're
not gonna see basketball courts break
out you know
they want soccer balls and they'll play
soccer barefoot and they'll outrun us
right in their bare feet so let's just
you know i think it's you know to your
point right i mean it
you know it kind of is it's kind of is
what it is and
and uh
our guys would see it because our guys
would stay there and you know
all the boots and the shoes and the
jackets and you know they don't wear
hooded sweatshirts you know give them
blankets right they're not going to
sport a
hooded jacket with a hood on it in the
middle of the afghan villages
they stick out like a sore thumb it's
not what they wear right so
you know they like cooking equipment you
give them cooking equipment
they make a great stew
you know
you might pay for
it for a few days if if you eat it on
our stomach right and the other thing
that we were doing was we were
introducing medical supplies
that were causing more harm than good
because
we needed the medical supplies because
the way we grow up and live in america
our immune system is much different than
what they look and i used to tell
stories i used to tell a doctor we'd get
an afghan in with a head injury right
and a bullet wound through the head
right
and the guy
he's expectant and i go oh no i wouldn't
be so sure please don't call them
expectant this is an afghan they have
incredible healing um
just the way it is
i get a call from the doctor the next
day hey don you're never going to
believe this the guy's sitting up
spouting all kinds of things and and you
know posh too and i go of course he is
he's an afghan
yeah you know that might have put down
an american
soldier
but not an afghan that's just the way
they are so please you know i used to go
over when our when our afghan partners
would come in and i would make sure and
say please and i'd have my medics there
and i'd say
just watch this guy because they're
going to say expectant and we know that
he might not be sometimes yes
most of the time no
and
you know
they just have a
different constitution because of the
way they have to um
you know operate and if we bring in all
of our
amenities
we weaken them and we make them more
susceptible to getting sick
and and dying yeah and it's not their
their way of life it's not their way of
life and and they don't want it right
you know they do have their idea of
of uh medical care so don't exceed it
right just
come up to it bring it back bring the
doctor back back bring the nurse back
bring those skills back
that the taliban had attributed down to
nothing
and that's what they need
so those so those two deployments back
to back that's 2000 was was it 2006 2007
so it was 2005 to 6 and six to seven
yeah
and those so what what type of
operations were your guys doing because
because now you were the
first battalion commander of third
special ford what what operations were
you guys were your guys doing so we were
doing uh we were assisting the afghan
national army at the time with uh you
know um
shaping uh and clearing operations right
and then we'd want to put we'd want to
hold that area in a way that we hadn't
been holding it before so we introduced
kind of the hold because it used to be
shape it go clear it and then leave and
then they'd come back in so let's hold
it let's figure out a way to hold it and
that's where the first
ideas about
bottom up security
came into play in 2005 six and seven so
you're so you're setting up uh what was
it afghan police was it local police the
idea of afghan local police right came
in there um and at that time we were
just calling them the arbi right and we
had the support of the and arbikai means
like security local security yeah it
means their local security so like back
in the day when they were fighting
alexander the great and genghis khan and
the brits and the russians
the
kabul the king of afghanistan
wouldn't send down national troops to
deal with the problem he would organize
local
arbites
and the village elders and the tribal
elders they'd go and they'd get their
weapons out of their you know
out of their huts and they mud huts and
they would come and they would report
and
they would defend afghanistan yeah and
that's how they would do it yeah there's
so many similarities you know from from
my experience in iraq and and in 2006
and in the city of ramadi
the
when the the army came in
look the army worked hard they when the
iraqi army came in they worked hard they
they sacrificed greatly they fought hard
they were a bunch of shia
going into a sunni city and that right
there you're already starting off on the
wrong foot i mean and that's not even
pretty that's putting it extremely
mildly just say you're starting off on
the wrong foot you you deal with people
that
have a history of killing each other
and so you got the strong shia army
coming into the sunni city and look
the sunnis inside ramadi realized look
the they're after al qaeda they're after
these insurgents they're after these
foreign fighters so we were able to
to get through it
but it wasn't until
the
the the
sons of iraq and the iraqi police the
local
the local sunni tribesmen tribal leaders
the sheikh said you know what we want to
defend our own city let us put our tribe
let us put our tribesmen in the police
force that's what we did and then it was
a game changer because now you had the
local tribal leader had his tribesmen
with police uniforms on
authorized by him
saying yep we're we don't want bad guys
here
and the local population is going up
that's that's our tribe and there's
several tribes there multiple tribes but
they all agreed that that's what needed
to happen so this idea of
you know decentralized command but also
this idea of hey the people that are on
the ground that are from there
they know who's good and who's bad and
the local populace is going to support
the neighborhood
kids that are now neighborhood police
and that's just it's it we were lucky
enough to kind of watch that unfold i
was lucky enough to watch that unfold
and and see those
the what they called the sons of iraq
and it was interesting too because
in iraq there had been there had been
out in al qaeda the marine corps had
pushed through al-qaeda and when they
did it there was a bunch of locals going
hey there's bad guys in that building
over there just bad and so the marines
said hey you know what let's organize
these guys and they made this this thing
called desert protector which was
hey if you're a local and you want to
help us out cool you can join this
program called desert protector
and they started this and it was working
pretty well
well
when maliki got elected all of a sudden
he looks out at al-anbar province
and they got all these desert protectors
out there and he goes wait a second
now i got a bunch of random rogue uh
security forces running around
i can't have that i can't i can't have
that so he shut it down
which
which was not a great move but you can
see from his perspective he doesn't want
a bunch of rogue paramilitary units
running around
but we were able to convince the the
shakes in ramadi because they were
asking we wanted you as a protector we
want to do that
we were able to say look we can't do
desert protector it's not around anymore
but you can be iraqi policemen
you can be local and we'll help you
train and that's what we did so what
you're talking about it's very similar
very similar yes yeah well
you know i mean
as you pointed out the the cultures are
you know very similar uh in the way they
approach things and there's the
principles that really work and apply
from one place to the other the
techniques and the tactics
and the approach might require
adjustment but nonetheless the standard
principles remain the same and that and
that's what you're talking about
and
i think
that
one of the
biggest things that we saw in 2005 to
2007 was that this broad bottom-up
approach has merit over a top-down
approach right although there are
aspects of the top-down approach that
you still need to apply
but really if you're talking about
security and safeguarding
a population and making that area
an area that the enemy can't operate in
uh
that's going to be the way that you need
to go and from 2007 five to seven we
learned that but the other thing that we
learned
was during this time frame you know
the us
you know transitioned the mission to
nato and that's when it became a
full-fledged nato operation
and a very good friend of mine dave
frazier who's written a book about
afghanistan and about his time there
during this time took over
that's when they went from
o sixes colonels
and in some cases navy captains
commanding the regional commands you
know north south east and west
uh in afghanistan to general officer
level headquarters and dave came in he
was a canadian special ops guy
who i had had a relationship with a
really really good guy
and
when we got into
afghanistan he said hey
i need you to come over here i need to
talk to you about you know what we're
going to do and how we're going to do
this because we got a problem
and uh
warren
we came in here to do peacekeeping
operations and
although it's not popular thing to say
my assessment is is that we're fighting
an insurgency and a deadly one
and he knew that that was our assessment
as well our intel guys and everybody had
the same assessment uh going in there
from first battalion third group
and our group headquarters
uh up north so
anyways
um
he called me in and
we said well i think we can come up with
an operation
using the afghan
national security forces
to come up into this district panned
away
and take over this stronghold of
insurgents right
and so
we went back we did some planning we
came back and briefed him and so what
charlie company
first battalion got the mission
and it was a
instead of coming at them from
you know uh kandahar province you know
directly or hellman province where they
expected you to come
we went all the way down south into the
red desert which is the red desert now
when you fly
in southern afghanistan
and you're flying
uh you know east to west or west to east
there's the red desert that heads all
the way down into pakistan and it's
nothing but desert
and then there's a distinct line that
goes into the built up areas and the
green areas and so on and so forth
and it's just so blatant nobody goes
down there only better ones go down
there
so
we did
our infiltration in the pandu weight
district that way it took three days
we did vehicle recovery operation i mean
it was ugly right but we got there
and
completely surprised the taliban in
panjoy and it was a huge victory
so we
routed them up and then
um my guys were up for
over 96 hours straight
me and my command sergeant major went in
once we took
panjoy district
and this is where i told you earlier we
got up on top of the hill and saw
saw all the taliban coming it was
unbelievable
well anyways once we got control of that
situation
our guys mike those guys hadn't slept
for 96 hours and i called my
headquarters and i said hey i'm going to
stay
sergeant major and i'm going to stay
here overnight so cancel the
ch-47 coming to get us
and so we did that
and
i knew if i had told my guys that the
sergeant major and i were going to pull
the entire night shift so they could
sleep
i would have got a bunch of pushback
right now sir you're not going to be
pulling guard yeah i would so i just
kept my mouth shut and i said hey i'll
take first watch
and they go oh you don't have to do that
and i go no i'll take first watch well
these guys went down hard
and the sergeant major and i just stayed
up all night
well about two o'clock in the morning my
company commander jared hill comes out
he goes sir what the heck's going on
it's two o'clock in the morning i was
supposed to have shift you know i slept
through it i'm sorry i go no no no we
got this
go back to bed we're good
he didn't argue with me he went back to
bed uh and
um
uh
none of them
had to pull shift it was just me and the
serge major
uh and we did radio watch and did the
whole thing and we called in all the all
the times right and and that was that
and
these guys got up
not only did i have that but i also had
the helicopter come in with hot chow
right hot breakfast right
and so i said you guys
get your hot breakfast and now sergeant
major and i will hand it back over to
you and you know you got it right and
um
you know
it was just
amazing what these guys had done
general fraser in his book
writes
today about our guys and he says
they saved the nato mission because if
we didn't have these special ops guys to
do this
we would have been routed by the taliban
and it would have been a huge political
nightmare for nato
first battalion third group
my guys
got awarded
for the first time
the
equivalent
of the canadian presidential unit
citation
the only
foreign military in the history of the
canadian military to get that award
and they got that award and it sits in
the battalion headquarters at fort bragg
proudly and you know they sent down
their their equivalent to their
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff to
fort bragg and all the guys got got it
pinned on him it took him
uh
four years to get it approved but he
didn't quit and he finally got it proven
and i was i was just getting out of the
war college at that time was 2009 when
the when they when they did the award
and i was just so proud to see these
guys get the award and
do their thing but
um
yeah it was
i mean and that that's really what
what kind of got us thinking and you
know who got thinking
general mcchrystal
and when he came in in 2010 to take over
he was all about bottom-up all about it
and then when general petraeus came in
to take over for him oh he loved
village stability operations and afghan
local police and
so when when you before we get into that
so you get done with your battalion
commander tour mm-hmm
2007 something like that yeah yeah july
of 2007. then you change command and
then you go to war college
uh yep i go up to use of sock
headquarters for
from from basically august to
may
of 2008 and i get selected for the war
college and i go off to the war college
but
another great opportunity
when i went to
our three-star headquarters
which is a place nobody wants to go but
you know you go there i got put in the
to be the deputy g8 and the deputy what
the g8 does in that headquarters is
they do
they do all the
combat developments and the resources
and the budget and you know all that
stuff and so i learned that and then i
learned how usesoc not only fits into
socom and how we compete for resources
there but also how we compete for
resources in the army and how our tier
one guys
how they get all their resources and how
the rangers get all their resources and
everybody and so that was huge right and
so i was right in the middle of that
process because we were right in the
middle of
of doing all of that
uh for the next five years
and i got put in charge of um
of the uh movement of seventh group
from fort bragg
to
destin florida
for their new headquarters in setting
that up and what that would look like
and although not perfect
we really really did
create
an optimal
special forces group headquarters with
all the ranges and all the things
associated with so they could do all
their levels of training right there
and what you learn about working with
communities and briefing communities
because there's noise things and noise
studies and this that and
housing issues and you know is there
going to be enough housing you know how
is this all going to i mean it's just
unbelievable right so that was another
part you know like i told you before
with the secretary of the army and then
working at asd
and then the joint staff and all that
all coming together really gave me
tremendous insight on
on how ususak you know united states
army special operations command works
and again we've got a lot of guys that
make very senior ranks and don't have
any idea how that works because they
don't get the opportunity to go there
and that was because i come out of
battalion command i get selected for the
war college and it's like oh now what
the hell we're going to do with them
right
they had no place for me right
and they said report the use of sarc
headquarters and they'll have a job and
i originally
was going to be in the j in the g3 but
then i got stuck i got moved over to the
g8 because an old boss of mine was the
was the use of sock g8 um jeffrey putz
and he goes oh no no
i want him
right
he's a farm boy you're gonna work his
ass off for me right and uh
and he may not like it but he's gonna do
it and so boom so i went there and yeah
it was great great really great
experience um wondering how that worked
and then what'd you study at war college
so i went to the war college and i just
studied that you know their curriculum
and you get a master's degree in
strategic studies
so i was like ah this is great right so
i i've worked at the strategic level
right in three different assignments
and i've worked at the operational level
and now i'm going to go and i'm going to
get an education
uh in the in in strategic studies and so
it really
it it brought together the job
experience and then an education and
kind of mesh that together for me
i got a business degree when i went to
commander general staff college
because i i'm like you know what when i
take over a unit
it it can't shoot move and communicate
like nobody's business right
but god do we suck at admin
budget you know all that stuff that
nobody likes to do and they're not
comfortable doing it so i ended up you
know i got a business degree because i
thought that that's what officers do
right
and so
learning how to run a business
i said you know that's going to help me
out and it did right so i had the
business thing going for me and then i
had the
got you know got to the war college
uh
carlisle and and that was just a great
experience there as well
and um uh
but i learned one thing at the war
college it's not necessarily the war
college and what you learn there
it's winning
the jim thorpe sports event
where all the war colleges come to the
army war college and you compete
right
in a variety of different sporting
events
and
the army has only lost it twice
who'd they lose into history of they
usually you lose it to the navy war
college
the
what are the events the national war
college their teams are so small right
because the school is so small they get
their butts kicked all the time but the
army war college and you know you got
the army the air force the navy
the coast guard academy you know you got
all those guys that come down uh and
it's a it's three days of feats of
strength right
i loved it uh and and you
you play all these sports right during
the war college
only so that the coaches of the
different teams in the jim thorpe sports
competition
can draft
their athletes
and then you start training
in january after the first of the year
you get put on a team
and then you train all the way up to
uh
uh may
when they have the event what what what
event did you do i
i was in the uh 800 meter relay
and the five mile run
and
we won both those events um
we had a ringer we had a
uh some guy with a 357 mile or something
we had a
a guy on our team he was a marine on our
relay team who
was a
you know division one
uh relay
national champion
yeah on a team right yeah and that's not
fair and and our coach
was in the
1972 olympics
as an 800 meter
relay game
and so the coach
you know so he taught us you know how to
run you know and and how to pace
yourself and how to do it yeah it was uh
a blowout uh it was pretty cool uh but i
had the um
what leg that i have i had the first leg
yeah that's right i had the first leg he
even knew how to set up people for the
what legs and yeah you know and he stood
right right at the place and he said
turn it on
so as i ran by he goes turn it on and it
was you had so much left in you
right
even though i was last i picked
everybody off right and that was the
whole idea of it because people don't
get trained on how to run it they just
go
you know and two laps yeah around a
track yeah you know you're gonna start
feeling it yeah you know no i
the 800 which i never did but i was
reading an article about it somewhere
along the way and the 800 they say is
like the most painful event
because you know you're running 100
yards it's over yeah you you run you run
a mile or a 16 or even a marathon
it's at a lower level of intensity
he and this this article that i think i
read i think it was an article i read
but it pointed out the fact that there's
zero recreational 800 meter runners they
don't exist there's marathon there's
people run marathons there's people that
do little sprint triathlons there's no
one that just guts through
800 meters like for fun it doesn't
happen
all right so we wrap with the uh
jim thorpe
championship that's right and it's time
for you to go back to work
and your next your next thing is you go
back do you go back to afghanistan again
i do i go back for afghanistan again
what proved to be
22 months
and this is what 2010 2000 2010.
um and i go back to afghanistan
as an advisor to the
rc south commander
and at the time it was a dutch commander
by the name of
a major general decrees
he was a dutch guy
and we were having some
general mcchrystal was concerned about
the
problems with soft coordination so he
said hey you're going to take command of
siege soda faye so
so the siege is a that's the that's a
combined joint special operations task
force afghanistan this is the person
that's going to be in charge of all
special operations in afghanistan that's
correct and you get you get tasked with
that outside of
the the tier one guys right yeah
uh tier one guy's not included so um
uh anyways we uh
i'm gonna take command of that that's
going to be my brigade level command
opportunity and i couldn't have been
more excited i have admiral olson
and general kearney to thank for that
they're the ones that picked me so i was
um had a great relationship with admiral
olsen and general kearney general
kearney was then the deputy
the deputy of uh socom but
before that
and during my time as a battalion
commander he was the sock special
operations command central commander as
a two star so that's how i built that
relationship with him
and
uh general olse or excuse me admirals
i developed ignite a good relationship
with him and so they picked me for that
command but there was some time there
so i went to uh i said hey i'll just go
early right and i'll
you know um
do whatever you need me to do i'll work
on a staff i'll do whatever
you know pick staples out of the rugs i
don't care just you know just get in
there early and get myself
you know ready for
uh you know the
command and they said hey
general mcchrystal wants to go down
south and be the special operations
liaison
to
general decruyff who was not uh very
happy about the coordination with his
headquarters in rc south and
the soft guys
so i went down there and i got myself
established and did that well
the interesting thing is general de
croix went to the army war college
and
there's 20 seminars in the army war
college and you get assigned a seminar
and
there's a 21st one and that's
for all the guys deploying
out of the war college whose families
stay right so my wife was in seminar 21
when i left she stayed right there which
was great continuity for her and the
kids
because they were there
my kids wrestled so one of them wrestled
for the high school so they were
that was just good continuity
and we thought it was only going to be
for a year
but it ended up being for 22 months so
they ended up staying there almost three
years which was really good for them but
general de croix went to the war college
and he was in seminar eight
and i was in seminary and we called
ourselves the eight balls and so when i
went in to introduce myself and he said
where you coming from and i said the war
army war college he goes oh i went to
the army war college too
and i go really
that's great sir i mean i loved it he
goes oh i loved it too i was in seminar
eight and i go well
so was i
and he goes no way and and we had the
same instructors the same guys there so
we were able to share that we were able
to share stories about being an eight
ball right
and it was automatic
you know
relationship establishment rapport and
everything
and so all i did
was
go to his morning meetings be available
for him whenever he needed whenever
there was operations coming up i made it
sure that they were deconflicted
and
i ended up
traveling with him everywhere he went in
afghanistan
on his plane
everywhere he went in the south that's
what he wanted me to do
and
it was
it was like simple and
general mcchrystal was happy because he
was not getting any more complaints from
the rc south commander
and
you know and uh and they were valid
complaints i might say right i mean you
know how that goes there's just so much
going on right and everybody's trying to
do the right thing and they're trying to
they're trying to get it done and you
know things slip so they get
those six now you know a colonel there
to make sure that doesn't happen and if
it does happen he got one guy to blame
me nobody else so it was good uh and you
know we just tighten that up
and you know
it wasn't just soft you know it was
conventional side it was all kinds of
you know everything's going the state
department and what they're doing and
then
the you know other things going on so
hey it just worked and how long did you
do that for i did that for
uh six months
[Music]
uh let's see from june to
yeah june to december six months and
then after that you took over let's see
just yeah i went home for two weeks
uh for taking a nice vacation yeah two
weeks two weeks went home for two weeks
came back
took command and stayed in command uh
of um
of the special operations there uh you
know the siege soda fe
uh
may of 2011.
um and this is
and this is when you started or
at what point did the did the vso the
village stability operations start at it
was it at this time yes so because i
remember i was getting ready to
well i retired in 2010 and i was i was
running training and as i was running
training we were starting to have guys
do training missions
based on vso based on going out and
doing tribal engagement and key
personnel engagement and going to meet
people in villages and having them how
they're going to set security and all
that stuff we started doing that in 2010
so i don't know exactly when it came
came to fruition
but from what when did it
so it would have been about april of
2010 okay
that it all started coming to fruition
because i got there in 2009 i did that
then i took command
yeah june of 2009 and then i didn't
leave until may of 2011 right
uh so it was
it was about that time frame
and
you know it was a it was a collection of
people that were you know putting this
together but i happen to be the
commander that did the bulk of
operationalizing it
which is the hardest thing to do right
the first guy in the breach right um you
know it's it's hard because you got
people pushing back against it and you
got people that are all for it and you
know even though general crystal wants
it to happen you know there's there's
many people there with him that don't
want it to happen and you got the
international community and
and even my own community right uh they
were skeptical of it because
they saw it as a special forces mission
so bringing in marsoc and bringing in
the seals to do this kind of mission
they were like hey that's not their
mission and this is a bad precedent and
this any other thing and i'm like hey
but you know okay so give me more odas
right i mean
you know i i came up with a term and the
joint staff uh because everyone was
using the word fungible right
and i happened to be giving somebody a
brief right and and
it was about using special ops and you
know we're better when we work together
right because we have just we just are
right so anyways um
uh i said and you know special ops puts
the fun in fungible
you know because that was the big
strategic word at the time right
and so the more you could show you were
fungible the better off you were so
we're fungible as hell right and and
that's what that's what we do
uh
so anyways we yeah we we just um
you know came together and did it and
every
single
whether it was marsoc whether it was uh
whether it was um you know their teams
or the navy seal teams or the special
forces teams
these platforms did really really well
and just give us a
quick brief on the idea of of the vsos
of the of the village stability
operations what was so if if i was an
oda team leader i was a seal platoon
leader what was what was my mission what
was it going to look like so your
mission is to go is to go into
say it's uh you know kandahar province
and it's district x
and you're going to go in there and
you're going to figure out what is the
best village
to start a village stability platform
which consists of your team
and
additional augmentation of intel guys
and other things that you're going to
need in order to be able to operate
there you're going to go in you're going
to talk to the village elders and the
tribal elders and you're going to figure
out where you need to be
now they're going to tell you where you
need to be
and you're going to go with it
and if it's the wrong place don't worry
about it we can change it
so just just go with the flow
just go in there
they're in charge they're the guys that
are going to tell us where to go and
over time you'll figure out if it's the
right place or not and then working with
them if you got to change the place you
don't want to because what's going to
happen is they're of this top-down
mindset okay the u.s is coming in and
they're going to come in with a whole
bunch of good stuff
and we're going to be able to take
advantage of it well they're going to
realize over time but we're not coming
in there with jack
right yeah just go talk to the odas and
the seal platoons that are out there in
the middle of nowhere that's right
and so some hesco barriers and a
freaking sackcall antenna have fun boys
right and we're not coming in with with
a big bag of money and a whole bunch of
things that they're going to be able to
you know take advantage of and then
they're going to realize wow holy crap
right
and but what we are going to do is we're
going to come in with the ability to be
able to prove to them that they can
secure themselves and we'll develop this
afghan local police program and they're
in charge of nominating the people for
this program so we we get their
fingerprint their thumbprint on that guy
and so if that guy does something
it discredits the village elder and the
tribal elder
so you're not going to really get back
at now did we have some problems yes we
did but the problems were minute and we
started
we started clearing these you know
clearing and holding these areas
and
with the afghan local police program and
yeah and it's based more on
relationships that you form with the
locals
more than it's based on imposing your
will on the locals right which you can
only do that if you've got the strength
and the consistency and to do that all
the time right which is it's impossible
it's impossible it's impossible it's
impossible and so some of the challenges
that i was presented with was hey you're
putting these guys in
in harm's way they're going to all get
killed one night
the taliban is just going to overrun
them and i said well
i don't think so
our guys are smarter than that they're
not going to allow themselves to be
overrun they're going to keep their
finger on the pulse on the intel we're
going to use the relationships that they
have in the pashtun wallet code and
people kind of laughed when i said
pashtun wallet copy
but it is strong you know and it
consists of you know
supporting strangers
it consists of revenge right
and
that's what they basically operate off
of and
they
accepted us in and we became their
responsibility
and um
as a result of becoming their
responsibility
then let anything happen to our guys
now did we get guys injured and did guys
get killed yeah but that was in combat
operations and they died right along
with us right
it's just combat operations or combat
operations but
did we ever get overrun no and this was
in the middle of the time where you saw
conventional outposts being overrun
right
uh and you know all over afghanistan and
this is conventional units that put
themselves
in
valleys
uh and in places that they shouldn't
have put themselves because
they were operating independently of the
the afghan culture's
protection right and so
ended up
by
2011 when i left
we had 90 locations
and none of them ever got run over none
of them ever got attacked
the afghans were all over it i mean they
knew and they never lost the fight
against the taliban
they they were protecting their families
and they took it seriously and when they
saw the progress they were making and
this big bad taliban guy
was defeatable
and they saw they were like whoa then
they got the will to fight
and they had the mission and they
realized that that their freedom and
their destiny to live life the way they
wanted to live was in their hands
and that they didn't need
the american military or international
forces to secure their freedom for it
they could do it themselves
but we need your help a little bit right
we need your help a little bit but when
we got it we got it and that's where the
transition piece came in
yeah it's interesting because
you know i was saying that not only can
we as americans
impose our will on every village in the
country guess who else can't do that the
taliban the teleman that's right so so
if you got it you got to make those
connections it's decentralized command
it's building relationships and had a
pretty positive i mean a very positive
impact on what was happening in
afghanistan 2000 what was that 2010 2011
into 2012 and 13. things are moving
in the right in the right direction
right and
you know
like i said general mcchrystal put it in
place he was replaced by uh general
petraeus and general petraeus became a
huge huge advocate of this and one of
the things that general petraeus did
was
he
said don what do you need to expand this
and i said well we're kind of limited
sir with just our special operation
forces
but if we could get augmentation from
the conventional forces
then
we could expand right and we could
we could use the conventional forces to
augment
and not as
guards for our bases because we don't
need those we got the afghans to do that
but just as additional
people and we can train them on on how
to do it
but and then we can expand ourselves
because we have we have a little bit
more people but not too big because we
can't get too big because then that
that gets out of right so he went to the
army
and got us a battalion
right
and we used that battalion
to um
to augment not every team but certain
teams in certain areas and it allowed us
to expand faster
and one of the one of the areas that we
needed to do this was konar right
and we brought in a guy
by the name of jim gant who had
relationships with
the tribal elders out there both in
pakistan and in
and in afghanistan
and we gave him the village stability
operation mission
now gant worked for me when i was a
battalion commander
he wrote a paper that general olsen or
admirals and really loved
and so did petraeus and so did others
and they asked scott miller who was my
boss one star then two star
major general miller um
who was my boss during this whole time
and who i worked through in order to get
you know village stability operations
and afghan local police started and he
was pretty brilliant and and you know
how he got that approved through karzai
and so on and so forth because everybody
was
in the international community was very
concerned about oh
you're going to arm all these guys and
then they're going to
create all kinds of humanitarian
violations they're going to kill people
and you know karzai was worried that
they would get too strong and take over
the government but
you know when you go down there at that
level they didn't have those they didn't
have those aspirations they just wanted
to control their village that's it they
just wanted to live control their
village have their family
get their family educated
uh bring their crops to
market and live right
and not have anybody bother them they
they had they had no design to take over
afghanistan
because they saw kabul as a as as big a
problem as anything else right so
um yeah people but there's people that
live in
montana and wyoming that don't really
care what's going on in washington dc
and they certainly don't want to move
there they don't want to move to new
york they don't want to move to l.a they
they just want to live exactly exactly
and so same principle applies and so you
know they
you know we uh you know we we took
advantage of that and it cost
us
1 8 the amount of money that it costs to
make an afghan police officer or
military officer
or afghan police officer or army
and you didn't need big garrisons right
and they walked to work
so there's no infrastructure right and
it's the ultimate decentralized command
right it it really is it and and and it
it you know it was working and they
could sustain it you see
it wasn't anything they couldn't sustain
in the long run so
um
and every
place was different you know if you saw
one
village stability operation and one
afghan local police
uh in a village well you only saw one
right because they're all different
right and they're different because
you know different people are are making
it work right uh and the tribes are
different and the ideas are different
you go up north yeah the terrain is
different yeah the way they're making a
living is different yes everything's
different so
you've seen one you've seen one so there
there's there there isn't this there
isn't this like uh you know magic
formula where you you know you got one
and you take that one and you impose it
over here no all different right and
what i really liked was
we carved this up into marshall
territory into naval special warfare
territory into special forces territory
and i i would get the same guys back all
the time right they would they would
come in for their six months they would
out rotate out in their six months
and we got that kind of continuity right
and we weren't reinventing the wheel
where you know special forces are coming
in
it happened every once in a while
and i remember
when i took command to see desoto a
um
we were coming up let's see this was
april i said hey listen i walk into this
headquarters and i see all these lickeys
and chewies and all this
all these condiments and ice cream and
all this other stuff and i go hey if our
guys on the ground can't have this we're
not having it and that's just the way it
is right
and
let's talk about thanksgiving and let's
talk about thanksgiving right now it's
april
if they don't get turkey we don't get
turkey
right
and
we had
the technology we had refrigeration
units we could put out there not not tax
anything we had stuff that would run off
of
off of
one of those panels why am i having
solar panels and we had all kinds of
stuff
and we could you know
there was all kinds of innovative ways
that we could get turkey out to them now
some guys got the frozen butter balls
and they put them in the freezers and
they were good to go
but what about those that we couldn't
get that stuff out to
well i had this
i looked at ron reagan my my law guy and
i said hey you got to make this happen
and he goes all right well we're going
to happen so
julia fuhrman a
at the time a young lieutenant
log officer comes up with this plan
and she goes sir
we got it
i think we're going to be able to meet
your intent for thanksgiving and i go
all right well let's let's get it
operation turkey drop
and our
um
our guys figured out how to
drop live turkeys in
and i said okay is this going to be cost
prohibitive or what and they go oh no
it's it's great we do it with the normal
runs but we just you know we have got
our own shoots we pack our own stuff
we've done
uh several rehearsals we haven't had any
misfires
so i'm not gonna get in trouble with
peta by dropping in a turkey and the
turkey you know the parachute doesn't
you know i was just kidding of course uh
and and uh so we did it we did operation
turkey drop we got them out there in
september all the turkeys
because we had to drop grain and feed
and
you know we had to tell them how to take
care of the turkeys and so they did it
and on thanksgiving day i got all kinds
of storyboards right of these guys
eating their turkeys everyone's happy
our guys are happy because they get
turkey and all the fixings went out
there with it right i mean boxes of um
stove top stuffing and then you know all
that good stuff right and so these guys
are eating that stuff well come january
i happen to roll out to our uh one of
the marine detachments out there and at
the time the young captain there was the
son of the commandant of the marine
corps
and i was going out to see him and
i land on the ground and dust settles
and the next thing i know
i got these two humongous turkeys on
each side of us and i go what the heck
are these guys doing out here and he
goes because oh those are those are our
turkeys you know i go these the same
turkeys that we've dropped to you and he
goes yeah yeah yeah and he wants to get
off the subject as fast as he possibly
can but these turkeys are snuggling up
right next to me and he told me what
their names were
and i we continue to walk and we closer
we get to the range the turkeys break
off and they go into this tent
that's got and i walk over and they go
no no sir it's this way and i go no i'm
going to see what the turkeys are doing
the farmer in me is now very interested
so i go over to see these turkeys and
they got this like
they got they're hooked up they got hay
and you know place to eat and drink and
tables that they jump up on and all
these things and i go what's going on he
goes
he goes oh yes sir
and he's looking down at his feet he
goes
the guys
they got the turkeys out here they named
him
the guys just fell in love with them and
they couldn't kill him
and i go you steely-eyed marine special
operators couldn't take take two turkeys
down for thanksgiving
we couldn't do it and i go all right
this is great
and i said hey i don't blame you you
know i get it uh and
uh
but he goes you know the afghans are
waiting for the day
[Music]
they're waiting for the day yeah cooks
right
and so
a special forces oda which i was getting
my point is we didn't always have the
flexibility of
replacing marines with marines and so on
and so forth
but
sf oda gets out there
and that next sunday i got a storyboard
and they're eating the two turkeys
they didn't have the same connection
with those turkeys
and the afghans the cooks they're all
smiling you know they got there you know
they're all happy but anyways
then uh so you were in that tour um for
22 months you're over there in
afghanistan
and then what what happens when you get
done with that
so i get done with that uh and they say
hey you're gonna go to the joint staff
and you're gonna be the deputy
uh
deputy special operations uh guy in the
joint staff
and i'll be working for uh general
negada
now the the the vso
idea
seemed to have faded
and and lost some of its uh steam not so
much from what was happening in the
field but it seemed like we went in a
different direction
yeah what caused that well when i got
back
so i went to the joint staff uh reported
there in june of 2011 worked on the
staff
and
there was emphasis taken off of village
stability operations
and afghan local police from 2011 to 12.
but
i got told hey
you know general or admiral mcraven
was now the
socom commander and
general allen was the commander in
afghanistan and they wanted
more emphasis placed on vso so i got
told that i would be going back in june
of 2012
to june of uh 2003 it was going to be a
year anyways and they said hey
and and tony thomas was going to be the
commander there the two star commander
and i was going to be the one star sif
sock a commander
with the portfolio for vso alp
and
i'll think of his name as we go but air
force one star
i was still a colonel i hadn't i hadn't
come out on the 07 list yet
but
the one star
was going to work as a deputy for
general thomas and he was going to do
all the direct action stuff right so two
portfolios one commander bringing soft
under one command
and you know tony thomas got that and
so
we went in there under that construct
and and i was told
get this back online
get it expanded so we did that
and by the by june of 2013 90 percent of
the
um
90 of the
rural area was in the control of the um
afghan government
and it was due to village stability
operations afghan local police
and
we started doing transitions so we were
transitioning
to the afghans they had put a
general ahmadzai became my battle buddy
and he was in charge
of the afghan local police
for the minister of interior
and
and so he was my battle buddy and i
worked with him to ensure that he could
he understood and could implement this
mission everything from
you know making sure they got the
training make sure they get the weapons
make sure they get the oversight make
sure they got you know they're doing
everything they possibly can and it was
integrated into the afghan government
fully and 100 and were out
and we had this on a timeline it took us
out about you know 2015 maybe 2016
and we would had completely transitioned
it and by that time
nearly 100 percent of afghanistan would
have been fully under the control of the
uh of the afghan government
the taliban at the time were saying
we're done
al qaeda
out you know
they were completely
ineffective again same thing i was
talking about earlier they don't have
the
they don't have the resources to be in
every single village and
get down to some local village with 280
people in it and
and put the resources against it to get
control of it and impose their will on
it
and meanwhile the locals
obviously they live there they're not
going anywhere and there's more of them
than there are the taliban capability
bill to do it so
it was
you know
it was just
it was heading into in a good direction
it was heading in a very very very good
direction and so
um you know by by the middle of by the
middle of 2013
um and and everything was you know
falling into place to where the afghans
and and none of the things that they
said
you know it wasn't a perfect
perfect program but what program is
perfect
it was good enough right and it was
working and a lot of the things that
people really had a problem with just
didn't happen right um
the
humanitarian
you know incidents didn't occur to the
extent that people said they were going
to occur and
and the
you know karzai was not concerned that
the afghan local police were going to
form
you know a huge militia and assault
kabul right it just wasn't going to
happen right all these things that they
at the political level they were really
nervous about just didn't happen
and so
i mean i mean it was good right
uh and and then you know it's it's it's
2013 and people are wondering hey when
you know when are we going to get out of
there and so you know the
political stuff started you know
filtering into afghanistan and you know
the ideas of pulling out and so on so
forth
by 2014 and transitioning
to non-combat operations
coming out of the villages and stuff
like that
and
so we tried to influence that the best
we could
with you know rand studies and showing
them that hey if we just keep this for a
couple more years
you know
it's going to be solid and the chance
for resurgence will be way low and i
mean i mean look what we've done in
terms of
the dropping of casualties you know
lowering of casualties record
lows
record highs and security
the taliban are pretty much slapping the
table on defeat al qaeda is like hey we
can't operate here anymore
and that had a lot to do with the top
down stuff going on too because you
needed that right so you know the tier
one guys weren't involved in in the
village stability operations afghan
local police but what they were doing to
take out the senior guys
was obviously complementary
complimentary right so this was good
this was a good balance and it was
soft was in a good place where
we were all working together and we were
doing a variety of different missions
along our very broad
mission continuum
and it was way less expensive than
sending over a division or a brigade to
do it right
you know did it keep soft busy yeah it
kept soft busy but
uh
you know i mean in a productive way and
the guys saw it right i mean not
everybody even our guys weren't in love
with the mission at first you know i
mean you talk about it in your book you
know about having to explain to guys
that it's going to have to be an iraqi
solution to this right and we're going
to have you know and it was the same
challenge as i had right
no guys we're not going to be kicking in
doors um the afghans are going to kick
indoors probably but you're not going to
kick in any doors and if you do well
that's an extreme right but you got to
work through with and by these guys
they're the ones that have to own it at
the end of the day and so we went
through the same thought process
but the guys realized that this was
still a combat mission that this was not
a mamby pamby kind of hand ringing
humanitarian thing
it was a combat mission and
uh and so
you know they got it i mean they they
they really
they really made it work
without them no way wouldn't have
happened
and so
yeah
so you start hearing this and
we're getting concerned
and the concern is about a drawdown
coming drawdown coming right changing
from a combat operations to non-combat
operations coming out of the village
villages too early
handing this program lock stock and
barrel over the afghans
at the senior level too early
and
you know we gave him the warnings we
said hey likely
the security situation will reverse
likely the uh there'll be a resurgence
and al qaeda will come back right well
nobody thought that isis would come back
but by 2016 we had a complete reversal
because we did we they made the decision
they slapped the table
we came out of the villages we went
strictly top down we put all our
emphasis on the afghan national army and
police
to
fight
and gain security
we didn't support the afghan local
police program anymore it fell you know
it fell apart
and
i think it could have been avoidable i
think a lot of other people who have
done assessments on it not it could have
been avoidable but nonetheless
you know our guys on the ground
regardless of what mission you give them
still do it
with
honor integrity and they get done what
you want them to get done but
at the end of the day
we saw isis come back we saw al-qaeda
emerge we saw emerge we saw
the taliban come back in full force the
security situation was reversed
and we had an all-time high in
casualties
in 2019.
so here we are in 2021
um and
uh you know president trump i think had
the right idea let's figure out how we
can come out of afghanistan
well nobody gave him a plan right when
he asked for two years in new
administration just didn't have plan to
come out so
um
you know hey the political situation
you know
overcomes everything right uh going into
a presidential election year a big year
for the congress you know
um
and that starts driving decision making
starts driving decision making and
really um instead of the guys on the
ground right exactly and so
here we go
and
you know
the president was responsible the
current president
who's got to make a decision right i
mean it it is what it is but
he was also in charge of when he was
vice president
you know coming out of iraq in 2011 and
going to zero and you know he
he just used i think what he learned
there
in the experience he had there and
applied it to afghanistan and boom you
know we're out lock stock and barrel
and
we
although i am an advocate of
you know figuring out how to come out of
there i'm more of an advocate of coming
out of there the right way
and there's a lot to lose there
particularly i mean i'm signing a lot of
letters today
from 20 years of working with people
there in afghanistan interpreters and
workers barbers you know guys you know
gardeners guys that really put their
life on the line
to um
to support us and to help us them and
their families and now they're left
there and and so
i think i got 45 letters signed right
now um and i send everything i do to
congressman crenshaw and tom
cotton because they're you know they're
putting together some sort of process to
expedite getting these guys out of there
but
you know
um
it uh yeah it's a
everything's political right and and you
know we just
we're you know we're at a point in time
now where
um
you know strategy and policy and
security inside our country and outside
our country is
is uh you know i mean i think it's an
issue i think a lot of americans
see it as an issue right um
yeah well especially when we see other
you know nation states that are making
moves big moves and playing long playing
the long strategic game and we're
looking to the next election that's our
long strategic game sometimes yeah right
now 2022 is our long strategic game
right i mean how are we going to change
the house and how we're going to change
the senate and how we're going to get
the majority there
not so much and how we're going to deal
with china and and how we're going to
deal with a potential invasion of taiwan
and how we're going to deal with russia
and their encroachment on the crimea and
europe and
and their pipeline issues and and iran
and and and you know their proxy war and
what they're going to do against israel
and north korea is going to follow china
everywhere it goes and now it's working
more on its nuclear program than it ever
has been and we got you know no
visibility on that and and those are
some ex those are some existential
threats that we really got to pay
attention to and they're real and
they're happening and we got africa
right 28 countries in africa that are
just getting eaten alive by china and
russia they're getting eaten alive by
terrorist organizations that are taking
advantage of the ungoverned spaces and
that's
dangerous for europe you know the french
and the british and the and the dutch
and the germans and
the italians the front line for the for
the war against violent extremist
organizations is in africa for them you
know it's mali it's libya it's tunisia
uh and uh it's uh it's kenya and it's
somalia and it's nigeria and it's
senegal and mauritania and morocco you
know
it's all these different places right
and
you know i mean i spent four years in in
us africom and uh two years 26 months of
that was commanding special operations
command in africa and we had 28
countries over 2 000
special ops troops on the ground
advising assisting training and
conducting operations through with and
by our partners
to get after
al-shabab right
sama isis somalia right
out in the east there central africa the
lord's resistance army and now isis is
there in nigeria with boko haram and
isis west africa
and and
in chat and cameroon and bikini faso and
mauritania and senegal and and all of
the uh
affiliates of al qaeda that are out
there wreaking havoc right the french
have over 4 000 troops on the ground in
you know from mali to nigeria because
it's their war on it's their front line
right
and you have a huge coalition of you
know
of european partners there i mean i
dealt more with our european partners
than special operations command europe
did
because they're fighting in africa right
and so i was always you know
coordinating with mark schwartz hey mark
i'm going to i'm going to denmark i'm
going here i'm going there you know i i
went to france five times right
to talk to the highest levels of their
government about you know
what was going on there um
and
you know uh so what was going on in
africa is is something that america has
taken its eye off of and
1.4
billion people by 2050 it'll be 2.4
billion people
and incredible amount of resources there
incredible amount of resources huge and
what goes through south america into the
united states
you know south america is
not very far from the african west coast
and you've got all those traditional
lines of illicit trafficking that go
through europe
iranians have multiple have have been
able to establish multiple places where
they have infiltrated africa all over
africa to move men weapons and resources
at a drop of a hat if they need to
so
i mean we got other problems out there
you know we have to keep our eye on it
in afghanistan we shouldn't be tied to
one country
uh but we got tied to that country there
was a good way to go out but
moving to a regional perspective
with everything going on in that region
is a whole heck of a lot smarter
and
you know we just need to start
considering that but we i still think we
have some responsibilities to
afghanistan that we kind of overlooked
in our
in in in our
in our um
exit there you know
you know you we
looking at the global perspective and
the global issues clearly um that's
that's all stuff we have to think about
but i know that there's one more issue
that you've dealt with personally and
you've tried to help out our troops
with it and that's
what's going on and what happens to our
troops and what's happened to our troops
well i guess as long as we've been
around but we've definitely noticed it
for sure since these wars kicked off
the war on terror kicked off and that's
uh
post-traumatic stress and and then the
the traumatic brain injuries
what was your
how did you
address that how did you experience that
what was that like for you and i know
we've been talking for a while but i
wanted to cover this because i mean this
is something that a lot of people are
are dealing with
yes uh well i think it's the number one
health issue that we have in the united
states military today and i believe it's
the same
when you look at our veterans and it's
leading to the significant amount of
suicides in both on
active duty in the reserves national
guard
and
and again in
a
veteran community right
um and i think it's all has to do with
this mental injury uh issue
and physical injury and spiritual injury
and it's that triad that i think is
hugely important that we have to work on
strengthening all the time
in the military because you know as well
as i do if you're physically hurting
you need that taken care of
and mental injuries right uh you need
that taken care of
and we know
by studying uh all the way back to
um
to sparta right
that traumatic brain injury and
post-traumatic stress was something that
they looked at they didn't call it that
right but they knew that a conch on the
head created problems right and they and
they manifested themselves in the inside
their their uh their their units their
military units and they they realized
that they had a
an obligation right in an ancient
spotter there's only two people that get
their name on a headstone a mother who
get who dies in childbirth and a warrior
that dies on a battlefield everybody
else is buried and spotted with no name
no nothing
but the birth of a child and
the sacrifice on the battlefield the
ultimate sacrifice on the battlefield
are recognized in that warrior culture
so when we look back and we see
everything that we've done and what
we've called it throughout the years
and and i was one that didn't have an
appreciation for it either right
i thought it was a sign of weakness
right there's no way right i mean you
know you think about patent and you
think about you know the way our society
has shaped us
and i thought it was weakness as well
until
it happened to me until i saw it happen
in others
until i realized was a problem and you
know who educated me on this my wife
she's a nurse she started studying it
she started seeing it she started seeing
how i changed every time i came back
and when you get more comfortable
being away from your family and deployed
in a combat zone than you do at home
with your family
you got a problem
and that was me
and it was affecting my relationships
with you know my family it was affecting
relationships in the military
i was
i was always
you know wired for sound and
go high and right really quick and lose
my temper not want to listen to people
and it just negatively affected
everything right and she started
noticing around 2008 and she was talking
to me about getting help while there was
no getting going for help in 2008 in the
military i can tell you that right now
in 2010 you started seeing programs and
they were starting to deal with
traumatic brain injury but
i'm telling you
we have all these programs but what i
learned was our approach is wrong right
uh it's our our approach is punitive and
we're going to take you off your team
and take you away from the people that
you love the people that you want to be
with every single day and we're going to
put you over here and we're going to say
okay you're not going to do your duty
you're not going to do your job and
and oh by the way uh we're going to take
your clearance away or suspend it
whatever
and
if you don't get better in a year
we're going to process you out of the
army i mean that's dod policy right
and i thought that was insane
well by 2013
um i just been promoted to brigadier
general i just got to us africa
u.s africom just started my job as the
operations officer there and guess what
my wife came to me and she said we can't
handle it anymore i can't handle it kids
can't handle it
your dog can't handle it you know
klondike are husky at the time
um
she goes
you gotta do something i gotta draw a
line here
she goes
uh
and i said you're right
you're right and she's talking about
losing your temper not being around
socially isolating myself staying at
work till ungodly hours just avoiding
avoiding social events
you know
the my biggest fear was having to go to
a social event right
and
i would look for every single excuse
under the sun
yep i'm going i'm going i'm going until
i call her i'm saying hey something came
up at work i could stay away right
check and i would go home right after
the event was done
so
and she's not dumb she knows exactly
what i was doing right
and
um but she knew it was delicate right
and you know
i wasn't a screamer at home i would just
not involve myself in anything
right
just come home
and mind my own damn business not get
involved and that was that and
you know
if something came up i would
exit stage right and avoid dealing with
it you know and then i would look for
every opportunity i could to
go deploy somewhere right well when i
went to us africom that ability to
deploy went away
because as the operations officer u.s
africom the only place i was deployed to
was my office right
that was it yeah so
in 2013 she got me to go
but i had heard about this nurse sarah
mcnary
who had
was up at lawn stool and she was really
innovative and so i went up and i had a
meeting with her and i said listen
you know
i got to do this under the radar right i
mean this is not something that would be
accepted by the chain of command if i'm
going for pts help
so
she understood and
she
put me on a program i went up
and it was easy for me to get away right
we had africom units up at launch duel
uh
and you know
ramstein near launch tool and i could i
could always find a way to get up there
if i needed to go for an appointment or
what have you so it wasn't a big it
wasn't a big stretch and it didn't put a
lot of light on what i was doing
but i went up there and three days
got evaluated post traumatic stress tbi
sleep disorder pain management issues
neurotoxicity
um
and uh it was all positive right i mean
all the malaria medications and the
vaccines and all these things we've done
all our career all life it was
my kidneys my you know
uh other organs uh the way
your brain thinks so on so forth uh all
that positive pts positive more
importantly i got put on therapy
programs right
and so i took advantage of this and i
did it religiously
from 2013
through 2015.
i managed to go through this
and then i looked at myself in the
mirror what do the therapy programs
consist of
so is this like sitting down talking
with someone is this yeah so they give
you a bunch of tests for pts right and
they figure out exactly what's you know
what's wrong with your um you know with
your brain and and you know with your
thinking and and how
uh social isolation is impacting you and
you know
and they put you with a therapist and
they work on those those things you talk
about it you come up with
strategies to overcome it
you
you my wife came with me that was hugely
important
because you know she's got there's a
quote
above my doctors
on my doctor's um
office there in launchdual
because my wife was with me and he asked
me a question and i told him my answer
and she goes
that's a bunch of [ __ ]
because she knows
so he goes oh yeah what's the real deal
right and so
i realized the utility in that because
sometimes we're embarrassed by our
actions right and we don't want to fully
disclose them well if you don't fully
disclose then people aren't going to
really understand how to help you and
and when i had to travel
and i had an appointment i did it by
skype and so i
the tbi i had serious balance issues i
my
eyes were out of focus and there's a
machine that they test that on and a
machine that they fix it on so my eyes
got back into balance and my balance got
they put you on a balance machine and
you know you feel like an idiot
and and i did all my balance uh
exercises my balance got good you know
there was i'd go for a walk with my wife
we'd hold hands and i would you know
veer off to the right
and she's like hey you're killing me
right and she pushed me back over and so
on so forth and so they just have all
these strategies to fix your now think
about it you've got traumatic brain
injury as a special operator and your
balance is off and your eye focus is off
and you've got to do
a you know high risk
ch
mh-47 infiltration into a village and
and then and then you know fast rope
onto a building and then use a ladder to
cross from one building to the other and
your balance sucks right these are
things we need to fix but we're not
going to be able to fix them if we're
not aware of them
and so i started thinking about what a
freaking coward i am
doing this under the radar and not
leading the way and so on and so forth
so
i went back and i talked to my boss
about it
as the operations officer in africa
and i said hey this is what i've been
doing
and i am a different man my wife sees it
my kids see it my dog sees it
i am different i'm not perfect but i'm a
better version of myself and
he goes yeah i've noticed you've been
showing up to our uh to our social
events on fridays here in africa when i
go oh yeah he goes before he wouldn't
come narrow i don't know i wouldn't come
near him no no no
and he goes he goes that's good
all right because i get it and i said
i'm going to open it up to guys in the
in the in the j3
and i did and i got them all together
and i talked to them and i laid it all
out and i told them what i was doing and
i said i'm a freaking coward but i tell
you what i'll do right now is
you want to get taken out of your job
you won't get taken you won't lose your
clearance i will back you up 100 i don't
care if it is dod policy
they
i don't care it's not the right approach
so i got your back we did it
and i'm telling you a lot of guys that
helped i carried that over when i took
command of special operations command
africa on 24 april
and i got with them
unbelievable
26 months of data
what i thought were
uh in discipline issues
with alcohol and drugs
was self-medication
those guys trying to figure out how
they're going to be able to
alleviate their pain deal with their
issues and still be able to do their
mission the best of their ability right
and
in
in south africa we put
even the deploying troops that came over
we put them through the program
and it was huge
navy seals marine special operators sf
air force guys
we got testimonies from wives and
marriages that were saved we
decentralized the uh the program like i
remember i was in niger
which we're up in arlit which is
in the middle of nowhere it's not the
end of the world but you can see it from
there you know what i mean
and
and i did my skype
you know
meeting with my therapist right i mean i
still see a therapist right
it's just something that i decided to
continue but i'm very high functioning
person and that was my point
these guys are still high functioning
and they're even more high functioning
if we give them the treatment they need
it's just a mental injury
52 people we we diagnosed with pts
with
traumatic brain injury
and there's only one guy
and you wouldn't believe how many people
with pain management issues right i mean
and sleep issues
we're the definition of a sleep
you know sleep problems yes we are and
and so we got them the machines or the
mouth thing whatever they wanted
and it was unbelievable
you know if you if you get less than
five hours of sleep
your brain operates like it's got point
one zero percent alcohol in it you know
legal limit of uh driving under the
influence
so for i don't know 25 years or so i was
shit-faced at work without without
taking a drop of alcohol you know and
think about your decision-making and
stuff like that and so
the new york times came into the unit
said hey uh we're going to do an article
on africa and then she started talking
to people he said that's not the story
the story is how we're dealing with
post-traumatic stress and tbi and
getting resilience and readiness back in
the unit that's a story you should ask
them about that
so she asked me about it i told her and
that became the story
i wasn't a popular story
with the chain of command not a popular
story at all and
i was told to stop talking about it
um the more you talk about it the more
problems we have and
i said well i don't agree with that i
think the more we talk about it the more
we understand it and the least problems
we have
uh and we get guys in the therapy and we
can do it without degrading the mission
i didn't i had 96
96 missions in special operations
command and 846 associated tasks and i
had zero
zero detriment in mission
uh
and guys got better i mean
drug and alcohol abuse you know
incidents went way down
i went to zero in misappro uh you know
uh misbehavior in the uh in the
workplace zero right
they sent a team from dod to investigate
what we were doing right and i said hey
it's just a matter of taking care of
mental physical injuries and spiritual
you know socom had a great program that
they brought in with that integrated
families and we had that and we located
it in our headquarters and that was
something that i had nothing to do with
because
the rules are that nothing gets reported
the chain of command and i'm okay with
that right i don't need to know right
guys there with their families working
out problems
it was really unbelievable
after 26 months of you know of this
and um
uh yeah uh
you know
it was for me it was
a whole process of
of leadership and learning
and understanding
and then being able to say
you're strong not weak if you ask for
help
right and i had three suicides in my
units i
i'll never forget sergeant first class
in kenya
six month rotation to kenya combat
operations with the kenyan special ops
rangers
uh against el against al-shabab and isis
somalia just great work
packed up all his gear
cleaned his quarters that he was staying
in
put a note
day before he was redeployed
went out to the range sat in a chair and
shot himself in the head
it was more painful him for him to go
home
at that point in time in his life in his
decision-making process then
um
so he took his life
i tell you what man i took a knee on
that one you know what i mean
i mean a big knee right
and um
so i said
we can't
we can't allow that to happen you know
it's bad enough to lose somebody in your
unit combat
but
suicide and of course
we missed all kinds of warning signals
everybody missed warning signals
you know who knew the family knew but
the family was afraid to talk
because
they were afraid that if they say
anything then it's going to hurt their
their husband's career
and so we need to be better at
making sure it doesn't hurt their career
make sure they get the help because we
can do it we get a lot of white space on
the calendar when guys come back we can
make it work
and taking these
health assessments isn't going to work
right you've got to have
take these programs and you at the top
i'm telling you rich paglisi who was my
senior enlisted advisor navy seal great
guy love rich i know rich rich and i had
the same issues and we would get in
front of the unit and we would talk and
we would share our personal experiences
and we had everyone's back the only
person that didn't
that got taken off was the sergeant
major of our
our
sift team you know our direct action
teams
and that's because
he took after we talked to him he took
all 45 of his guys the next day over the
launch tool ran him through the program
and when he was getting his mri
to see if he had any traumatic brain
injury
they found a tumor about the size of an
eraser on his brain
he got medevac to um
to walter reed they took the tumor off
they said hey
you know if you if this had gone another
year you would have been
figuring out an end-to-life plan
and they replaced his left hip that he
had been
uh you know
dealing with for years um and he was a
new man right
and an advocate of this whole program
and you know after he left the team
he went off to our training
and has been an advocate for this and
you know promoting it ever since and
this is what you get you get guys with a
better understanding from the bottom up
but they got to have that top down cover
and
i'm afraid it's still not there it needs
to be there we got to put it there
and
and you know i went through
the you know what everyone else goes
through oh i'm weak
something wrong with me
uh i'm less of a man
and
that's none of that's true
right
so that's
that was your last tour was was at sac
africom right that was it um
you know it was funny i joined the army
29 june
and i gave up command and had my
retirement ceremony on 29 june
2017.
i didn't retire officially until 2
august 2017
but you know i
came home and
went on terminal leave and started
helping veterans put together a business
called truth to power
um which um which i was doing really
well with um
i'd have about four speaking events a
month which was good just bringing in
the money that i needed
then i got hired to be an associate
professor at new england college and i
just got laid off and i was trying to
find a job i got laid off in may trying
to find a job so i ended up
applying to hampton police department
and i am now a at 59 years old a police
recruit in the new hampshire police
academy
i'm the platoon leader
and uh
my the youngest guy in the class is 19
years old
and i'm like holy crap right
and so uh i'll graduate in november uh
november 19th um
and uh
it was funny because in 1980 i was in
class number four because remember i
told you about being a police officer
and i am now in class 281
and so
uh yeah i'll start working uh working at
hampton police department which is the
town right next to stratham where i live
now in new hampshire
it's uh it's on the seacoast so it's
right there on the beach and a majority
of the the work there is patrolling the
the hampton beach area right which is
which is going to be cool and uh you
know it's going to be uh
high adventure
new hampshire baywatch that's right
that's right and uh you know i mean i've
always looked
at where i can contribute uh and i gotta
tell you at 59 years old when i
and it's quite a process too
because i
i applied and i got my test date of 3
may and i went in
took my test with 27 other
young guys right
and
that was
the standardized test right so i hadn't
taken a standardized test in over 40
years so i was nervous about that right
and i took the test that i passed much
to my dismay and surprise and i got set
up for my oral interview
and i had the lieutenant the sergeant
and the patrolman
and they go all right we know who you
are uh we all voted for you right uh in
the last election we know who you are
and we know what you've done for our
country why in the hell do you want to
do this
and i said hey just
looking for a way to contribute
and you know
there's no more to it than that and he
goes okay
and the sergeant starts asking me
questions and he gets to the patrolman
he goes
i
don't have any experience to ask you any
questions
and i said yeah you do you're a police
officer so bring it on but nonetheless
uh you know you do the polygraph and you
do the physical fitness test and you do
the
you do the uh the psychological test and
it was like going through special ops
again right uh you know all those things
that lead up to you getting in you got
to qualify physically mentally
you know you got to pass the uh the full
physical test
and i have
two
prosthetic hips and three prosthetic
discs
because of combat injuries and
that was the thing they were worried
about the most right and i said listen
i've jumped out airplanes with these
things i can certainly handle patrol
they go okay that's okay i guess you can
right
and uh
and so um my wife thought i was nuts
so that might seem like nuts and then
what seems like even more nuts to me is
you entering the political arena yes
what that what brought that about i was
asked
i was asked by
i got a lot of emails and texts and
letters phone calls
from people in all 10 counties in new
hampshire all 50 states
to include across the military asking me
to run for office
and
i thought well if people think i can
help them i don't have all the answers
certainly
uh not a politician um
and i think that many people in the
military would attest to the my my lack
of political acumen
because it's just not there too
straightforward blah blah blah but
nonetheless
um if you think i can help you i'm going
to try
and so that's my why for running
and
and so
um
you know i
i just want to help our country
our economy
help us become more fiscally responsible
and help us be able to improve the
safety and security of americans so that
we can all live the american dream
that's all i want to do
right
the oath i took in the military is still
valid i still believe in
and and
the american dream and and the greatness
of this country and and
i have a tremendous amount of of
exposure to
what other people in other places across
the world think and feel about america
and the promise of america
and i think that regardless of your
political beliefs or spectrum that you
fall on
you know god family community and
country
it's got to appeal to everybody and
that's my platform and that's what i'm
doing
and that's what you're doing right now
so what is it you're running for right
now just so everybody knows united
states senate in new hampshire
where you've lived for 59 out of 59 or
where you've been a resident of 59 out
of 59 years that's right um and i've
been a republican in that
state for 42 years my
18 years old
first president i voted for was
ronald reagan
[Music]
so
what's the when's that election timeline
the
primary in new hampshire so if i get
another republican that is going to run
against me which there isn't one yet
the primary election is in september of
and the
the general election if i win the
primary
against senator maggie hassan a democrat
who's been our senator for one term now
will be for november 2022.
i don't have a political machine behind
me
i got to get my name recognition up
fundraising
is huge so i've got to start earlier
than those that have already established
politicians right
and so
i'm out now campaigning
we're raising money we're getting our
message out there it's being very well
received
i've in the last poll you know
four months ago when they did a poll i
was at
30 percent
i'm now up at 45
right
so
uh we're moving in the right direction
so if people want to help out where do
they where do they find you where do
they go to help you out so my website is
dot www.dawnbaldic.com and you know uh
you can go there and you can either
you know if you if you want to help the
campaign out uh if you're in new
hampshire
that's easy to do
um you just sign up
you know everything is right there on
the website my positions are there on
the website so if you're interested in
how i feel on the second amendment or
whatever
it's there
and
uh
if you want to donate it's there um
you know i start pretty low
i ask folks
to donate 20 and 22 cents 2022 to my
campaign and if i get a lot of people to
do that i get a lot of money
and it's
you know
anything helps
five dollars ten dollars
twenty dollars and twenty two cents
two thousand two hundred
twenty two dollars yeah that helps too
uh but everything helps uh and um
and i'm just gonna go there to serve
there's 1.3 million people in new
hampshire
and i'm going there to serve every
single one of them
not just the republican party but you've
got to serve everybody once you get in
that office right you got to declare an
office and
you know my my political beliefs line up
as a republican
but
that doesn't mean that i don't i won't
work for and work hard for everybody in
new hampshire regardless of whether
they're an independent democrat or
libertarian right
and i think that's what we've lost in
this country with the political
divisiveness we can't come together on
three very important things our economy
fiscal responsibility and the safety and
security of americans we used to be able
to do that you know i'm a big fan of jfk
you know
i mean
big fan of him you know and
he would not even be recognizable today
right as a matter of fact he'd be more
of a republican than a democrat today so
we got to come together and we need
people that
i think have had
the experiences
in life
that realize that we're stronger if we
work together than we
and we are a part and are we going to
have our differences yes but
today our differences are just too much
too much around what's really important
god family and community
also you got social media too right dude
yeah we're yes sir we're we're on social
media uh everything um i would be remiss
though if i didn't didn't um didn't
mention the fact that
everybody that found out i was coming
here to talk on your show was like out
of their minds and it was across the
political spectrum by the way which is
which is uh which is really neat and
no no one more excited than my son
zachary who serves in the new hampshire
national guard uh he was speechless i
mean he was like
jocko oh yeah he just couldn't speak
right and he goes why didn't you tell me
and i go
i mean i don't know i mean i just you
know
uh but um well we have i i worked with
the with the national guard extensively
my uh deployment to ramadi they were
there when we first showed up and they
were just complete warriors and
professionals
and uh it was an honor to serve with
those guys
so i nothi nothing but love for the
national guard that's for sure
yeah he's coming up on his six years and
he's going to become a veteran he's
already made that decision but
nonetheless
i am proud that he served his country
and my youngest boy
matt is a senior at purdue and he just
finished his uh
his lieutenant training
uh so so they're upholding the tradition
he'll be a second lieutenant on active
duty uh look out another baldic is
coming fellas so
awesome that's probably probably a good
place to stop echo you got anything oh
yeah real quick going back to the
marijuana fields oh and this is going
deep yeah yeah yeah and you mentioned
booby traps yes like what kind of booby
traps are in them the no the the the
marijuana growers back in the day would
put booby traps around their marijuana
field so people who wouldn't sneak in
and steal their everything like what
kind of booby trap so you would get the
booby trap where you came across it and
it would be just uh it would it would
kick off like um
like a uh a ditch of uh like napalm
fire would come up also like violent
booby traps bombs
the old ones with um
like you like the you know
uh
you know
vietnam era stuff where
punji sticks and and they they would
they were spring-loaded kind of things
and they would come and they would just
hit you in the thigh or the leg or what
have you
upper body those those kind of things
yeah dang that yeah they were they were
serious they were scary
well because i'm quiet and this is bad
back in the day too when when it was
illegal but uh they'd have booby traps
but it would be they wouldn't be violent
booby traps they'd just be like alarm
type like you know like i heard one
where they had
just like cases and cases of mouse traps
so like if you sp if you stepped on it
you nudged it
and it was like like you know like a
bunch of birds taking off or whatever
but louder it'd be something like that
like that kind of stuff they had those
two violence early early warning devices
yeah yeah they'd have that and but they
also had the closer you got
the worse off it was for you and that's
why the
the um
the the forest rangers were always you
know they were very appreciative of us
going in there because we'd take it very
slow and you know our guys were trained
very trained very well and we had you
know we had some technology to help us
out as well so
uh but yeah it was there
it was ugly
and we're lucky that we didn't set any
of them off that we were able to
either go around them or you know um
neutralize them
different way with
you know old-fashioned way with uh with
the um
the rope and the
grappling hook grappling hook
pull them out and watch what happens
wow that was a good show
glad we weren't around that
right on yeah general any closing
thoughts
well i think the only closing thought
that i would have and since this is you
know you focus on leadership a lot is um
i'd just like to let everybody know that
um
throughout all this i realized that i
was uh imperfect leader
and that as long as i remembered really
three things and that is to remain
humble thankful and grateful
and that i never let my ego get in the
way
and i was always self-aware of my
weaknesses
and worked on those and let my strengths
be what they are
um
it was better off for me and everybody
else around me and
these type of shows and the things that
you do and what this show does for
anyone who listens to it
uh is is uh is hugely important
for america because right now
what we need more than anything else
is effective leadership
it is it is a huge huge
issue and
and something that i think
my experiences teaching in college and
being around my own kids and being
around others
is they're thriving for
for you know leadership in these
examples that we have seen in the past
and
and you represent that here with this
show and i just want to thank you for
this opportunity i'm i'm humbled and
grateful for it and
and so thank you for what you do and
thanks for letting me tell my story well
thanks for coming on thanks for joining
us
uh more important thank you for your
leadership
your service to our great nation your
sacrifices overseas it's been a long war
for america you were there for most of
it
and that's saying a lot and you are
still continuing to fight for america we
appreciate it
thank you god bless you thank you very
much
and with that
general don
bullduck has left the building
definitely uh
seen a lot
always looking to improve
i think that's something we can
definitely take away
maybe we can all look to improve maybe
that's a good idea echo charles yes sir
any suggestions on where we can start to
improve ourselves yes what do you got
well he did mention how he's
he didn't say he was the oldest one
cadet in the police uh i think it's safe
to assume he's the only one i assume
yeah
um but he did imply that he you know but
the fact that the point is he's out
there staying capable talking about
jumping out of planes with hips a
certain way to the extent where they're
like oh yeah you pass just you can do
you can still do this kind of stuff you
were this capable
you're in meaning the hips past mustard
yeah exactly right they're good to go
remember they they're like um oh you
would you know they're concerned about
his hips or whatever and he's like hey i
jump out of planes with these hips and
they're like oh and then you can patrol
that's right point is very capable high
levels of capability 59 29 19 years old
whatever
we're maintaining it
the clock is ticking the clock is
ticking i heard
so we want to keep ourselves capable
mentally physically of course right
through this path of capab capability
chasing we're chasing capability of
course through this path we're going to
take some beatings 100 take it from me
yeah
you do some jiu-jitsu you take beating
sometimes sometimes that neck gets
sometimes yes and they're gonna get
squeezed on that one so
you know how like i said hey after i
rolled with you that one day and i was
like man i like i feel like i got hit by
a truck and you're like oh yeah full
body doms right oh yeah
it's way more than full body doms
psychological
got some emotional doms as well
man and that's that's real you know
these are that's just one of the many
examples of the beatings you're going to
take on this path no problem though
sometimes you need some supplementation
to help you through those beatings in
fact you get through these beatings
that's when the capability starts to
emerge see i'm saying
additional levels of capability anyway
got some supplements for you
gonna help you help us so first
supplement i wanna talk about is a new
era of energy drinks straight up
like the the old new category new
category real category new paradigm
paradigm shift
one two three oh mia
discipline go yeah
so no sugar it's a healthy energy drink
straight up that actually tastes good
yeah i saw someone someone wrote hey i
thought jocko didn't drink energy drinks
i heard him say he didn't drink them
unless he really needed them well why is
that that's true that's a fact it's a
fact before
this came out because you weren't going
to want to drink one of the
other
the energy you weren't going to you
didn't want to drink those unless you
had to yeah
i've got a 19 hour drive
i'm 14 hours into it i'm fading i need
something to boost me up for the next
three hours okay cool overdose with
caffeine get your jitters on but you get
there yeah so that's what i used to do
for sure
now all of a sudden it's like oh i've
got something that i can drink
it's actually healthy for me
and it gives me the benefits of energy
right
it's a no-brainer yeah it's true so
do do i drink
traditional
old school poisonous
energy drinks the answer is no i don't
yeah i used to occasionally if i needed
to now
don't never need to do that again
because we have an alternative that's
functional yeah and works
so there you go and tastes good do you
drink kombucha no have you ever ever
tasted it i've probably it might have
almost touched my lips but like i can
just smell stuff and i don't like it but
that's wonderful oh kim kombucha is no
exception in that regard but it tastes
junk it tastes bad i know people
including people that i'm related to
that are so
down with kombucha okay i get i do more
females like kombucha than males i i
don't have those numbers in my family
that's what i'm going on my family
females are drinking kombucha yeah
kombucha what is it
kombucha kombucha they're drinkin it
females males not drinkin
my father-in-law straight up makes it
straight up it's like a process it's a
thing and then i assume he drinks it yes
sir he does
but
in my experience yeah more females
are into kombucha than males but that's
not the point the point is if you ever
tasted it you're like cool kombucha is
so healthy you know it's detox and
whatever they say about kombucha i don't
know i don't know that ain't worth it
it's healthy we'll just say bro tasty
you're like all right i'll endure that
taste for the health benefits you see
insane but there's no reason to do that
no no there's not that's the thing so
this one especially the mango flavor oh
you drink that one you're like wait a
second tastes good and healthy and gives
me energy
no no lose situation right there okay
just so everybody knows the the
the mango flavor there's no difference
other than the flavor yes you can't put
it over here on a pedestal of
whatever it tastes the best so you know
in your opinion yes
yeah i think and you know the consensus
is still kind of being formulated
because new
which is another kind of novel thing new
new flavor so you know you want to look
at that one i always go back to old
faithful jocko palmer yeah i can't i
can't argue with that right yep it's
legitimate yes sir jp danielle pointed
out that jaco palmer tastes good whether
it's like room temperature or whether
it's cold yeah you're good to go orange
is like that too for sure
so yeah get your oh yeah it's called
jocko discipline go if you didn't know
already which you know most of us do
know but we i do want to kind of
reiterate these things about it yeah by
the way it's available
in wawa right now and we're working on a
bunch of other convenience stores you'll
be seeing it
but everyone that's been going out to
wawa and just clearing shelves thank you
yeah because that makes the other you're
actually helping everyone in the in the
nation
you're helping everyone in the nation
because
other
convenience stores look at wawa and
think oh how's it go they go oh how's it
doing there whoa yeah you're selling a
lot of that stuff so that means other
convenience stores go all right we want
it to and they're saying that so we
appreciate east coast troopers out there
clearing shelves
in wawa
yeah it does make sense right if you're
uh let's say a convenience store owner
yeah right a guy who makes the decisions
whatever and he's gonna be like wait a
healthy energy drink he's gonna be
thinking kombucha or something like this
where it's like cool it's new might not
taste that good whatever but wawa's over
here demonstrating that hey brother it's
gonna taste good too you know so they're
like oh i get it now you know they're
kind of connecting the dots a little bit
yeah there's all this data
and it's been great so again
sincere appreciation everyone that's
been rolling out to wawa and just
getting it
appreciate it that's awesome and you're
helping america because now the rest of
other convenience stores are getting on
board
and then other people will have access
to this
wonderful
nutritious as
as travis mills said nutritious and
delicious nutritious and delicious
fully
also other items that can that do help
us on the path is we got some joint
stuff joint warfare super krill oil
another good thing for your joints um
and the thing is it's a big deal and
this is like we always say this is one
of those things where
this really pays for itself
in a way that's like invisible because
you're not worried about your joints
you'll feel the difference when you
don't have it
here's here's what's interesting
we have a massive amount of
subscriptions to those two
so people yes send it to me every month
because they want to not miss out on
that goodness yeah and then we're just
worried they don't want to worry about
that and if you want to subscribe to it
you get free shipping by the way which
is cool
we don't have to pay for shipping
you can also not pay for shipping if you
go to a vitamin shop you can get all the
stuff at vitamin shop they've also been
supportive
and everyone has been supportive rolling
in the vitamin shopping buying stuff so
very cool we appreciate it we'll keep
making milk we'll keep making things
that taste good and are good for you
yeah that's what we're doing
jackalful.com you know also
originusa.com
this is where you can get american-made
denim
shoe or boots some other all the cool
new stuff that pete thinks up working
pants got some jiu-jitsu stuff on there
as well so if you're joining jiu-jitsu
you don't have a ghee yet or maybe if
you do have a ghee
origin and they're always coming out
with some new keys yeah yeah i said that
in kind of a but let's face it
the geez at origin like i put a i have
the first like one of the first rift
geese i have i was wearing it yesterday
where were you yesterday i was at you
know somewhere okay while i was training
on the mats of justice sure i was
wearing the
first a dish
yeah white
rift key those things are freaking
unbelievable it's like a whole new
thing
era yeah a paradigm shift since you said
that earlier yeah yeah they're yeah
they're they're the best the the only
downside is that you will
potentially be spoiled and that will
throw away your other geese yeah or at
least marginalize them i had i put on
one to see oh yeah does this still fit
and you know feel it and you feel it
you're like bro i would never wear this
i mean cool respect oh you put on one of
the old ones the old ones yeah and it's
it just simply went out of the rotation
yeah and plus you know it has bad karma
why because it was made by a slave lady
yeah yeah
china yeah
yeah what's cool too is and we can you
can see this on the origin youtube
channel it's like it's the opposite of
slave labor it's like it's one thing to
be like okay you have slave labor okay
they don't want to be there they're kind
of in a way like obligated or forced in
one some way to be there and they got to
make this stuff okay that's terrible
obviously but then you have like maybe
the quote unquote standard where it's
like hey that's the job they're going to
go and they're going to do it then you
get origin you go there bro those their
way every single one you see them all
man they care they care about that
stitch you see them saying they care
about like the whole deal then they make
that ghee then you get to wear it
that's gay that's the then you get
positive karma good karma with that ghee
all around
good karma with those jeans the working
pants
supporting american economy as well
that's a big part of the whole gig
amazing yeah
so win-win wins across the board origin
usa.com cool stuff on there very cool
also speaking of cool stuff jaco has a
store
it's called
choco store
so yes discipline equals freedom shirts
hats some uh rash guards on there uh
hoodies on there schwartz on there
you want a shirt that says good
with or without jocko's face you got the
option though anyway some good stuff on
there check that if you look at that
stuff you like something get something
we do have a subscription situation on
there as well called the shirt locker
cool designs
depending on your opinion
sure but we think they're called general
consensus they're cool design they're
fun you know a little bit different so
we'll say creative i don't know i've
heard the word creative thrown around
okay nonetheless uh you can check those
that out as well it's all at jackal
store
subscribe subscribe to this podcast
wherever you subscribe to podcast you
can also subscribe to unraveling jocko
unraveling with daryl cooper we've been
making some of those lately we have the
grounded podcast which we haven't made
lately
does it need to be revived from the
ashes yeah it's possible uh warrior kid
podcast it's another one i got a i got a
letter from a little kid they had one
question for uncle jake yeah
when's the next warrior pawn kit kid
podcast coming out because i've only
made i think 37 of them or something
like that yeah
but they're there you've got a kid
warrior kid podcast we also have jocko
underground.com we have a that's a
little um
little
sovereign area of the interwebs that we
built to make sure that we can remain
free out here and because look these
people doing are all kind of weird stuff
with these platforms that we're on
so far everything's been cool it's cool
we appreciate it
but contingency wise you can't just
you can't build your house
on someone else's land
because they might come around and and
kick you off right so we made our own
land
it's called jockowunderground.com if you
want to help us
support that land if you want to if you
want maybe a little room on that land
maybe you want a little plot
yeah we can get you one
it costs 8 18 cents a month hey if look
and if you if you need to come on to the
land the sovereign land
of the jocko underground and you can't
afford it it's okay we want you there as
long as you're in the game you can just
email assistance jacounderground.com
that's we appreciate it again for real
if something goes sideways on these
platforms we're going to be there
and and as a as a appreciation we do
another little podcast it's usually
about an hour we talk about some other
subjects we answer q a
questions that have been sent directly
to the underground that's true then we
cannot tell you what's up so that's that
we also have a youtube channel
and a lot of people correctly identified
on the latest release of the mayhem
movie sure that echo charles made sure
a lot of people recognized that there
was a some powerful assistant directing
going on in there
i'm serious i saw
i'm the assistant director yeah and uh
and also you know kind of
i had a supporting role in that yeah one
would you say i think so actually you
might have been the lead on that one i
don't know zero lines yeah which is they
they were powerful though that's the
thing your zero lines because your whole
performance is powerful because big
shocker
echo made a movie and he's the star of
it that's kind of the feeling that most
people got
like
it was a clip of us talking about it or
whatever and
um how like you know that the time
you're you're clicking on the can or
whatever in the in that video or
whatever it gets me i guess at the end
of the day i was giving you props for
that uh-huh or whatever yeah and
i feel like everyone including maine
thai is kind of just sort of recognizing
you straight up you're the ad assistant
director so
i still feel like i'm in the shadow of
the star yes the person with all the
lines yes and the most camera time yes
yes you are you are no that's you dude
yes our youtube channel we do have uh uh
on top of
jacqueline the assistant director we do
have the video version of all this stuff
if you want to see what general don
bullduck looks like you can come on here
yeah and check out the youtube channel
youtube is you know one of those things
now it's not just a video thing anymore
it's like some people it's their
preferred method to like watch tv listen
to podcasts or whatever so i dig it and
we got you that's where we got this
whole thing i think i'm one of those
people
yeah
i
mean does anyone watch tv like actual tv
like a show yeah is that happening yeah
okay
some dvr action okay i don't know if
people still watch it live like live no
i don't think so like that might be
connected very low numbers objected to
commercials and stuff
so commercials
are kind of a non-starter for me at this
juncture of my life yeah you know what's
weird in my kids kind of the same way
is like i like i like commercial not all
of them but well fast forward to them
but if i see one then i'm like oh wait
let me see that commercial like it's
kind of there's no commercial there's
like a because some commercials there's
a little story within the commercial
it's kind of good
i feel that way
a little less so yeah anyway yeah the
point is we have a youtube channel boom
subscribe to it subscribe to it if you
want it's a good one
so yeah there you go also psychological
warfare
if you don't know what that is an album
a jocko album with jocko tracks on there
telling us how to get past our moments
of weakness when we have them and i have
them from time to time
but you don't got to worry about that
kind of stuff because doc will tell you
why you should get over them 100
uh success on that one 100 if you want
to hang something cool on your wall
why not make it something from
flipsidecanvas.com
that my brother dakota meyer made owns
he is the i want to make fun of how do
we make fun of him he's the creative
artistic director of that thing
there you go dakota creative artistic
director i think that's the title he's
always wanted yeah i don't doubt it it's
a good title that's dakota one of my
heroes and if you want to get some stuff
to hang on your wall flipsidecanvas.com
got a bunch of books
i've written a bunch of books the one
that's coming out next is called final
spin
we don't know if it's a novel we don't
know if it's a poem we don't know if
it's a manuscript we don't know what it
is but it tells a story
a story with some lessons
i let my oldest daughter read
the book
final spin
and she got done reading it
and she came out the kitchen and
like i could see that she just got done
reading it
and i go oh well you know what'd you
think and she started explaining to me
what she liked and what she didn't like
and she started crying
while she was explaining it
that's when i said to myself okay looks
like i found it it's like we got it we
got what we wanted yeah that's funny
which is to have some kind of an impact
right that's what we want yeah i want
that thing to leave a mark a little bit
you ever think about that like why
do we ever cry during the movie no
come on bro zero when you're young you
never cried there in the morning oh no
we're not you didn't say when i was
young ever yeah when you were young
whenever yeah yeah one movie uh
i'm pretty sure e.t
you know what sucks is i watched et with
my daughter who's when she was 11 when i
watched it with her this was just like
this year have you seen e.t lately no
not lately uh steven spielberg no
offense that movie did not stand the
test of time
hey i went to the theater when i was a
kid and i saw that movie and i was with
a friend of mine and we were kind of you
know little tough guys we were probably
10 something like that little tough guys
you know
and we were bawling
and i watched this movie what part is
the end of it or something i don't know
he goes home i mean eventually right
that's like well it's supposed to be the
so i watch it with my daughter and i'm
sort of bracing for her and i'm thinking
all this is gonna be
she
she just it was bad
it didn't stand the test of time now
look jaws
as you know i mean jaws one of my
favorite movies steven spielberg good
job credit that stands a test of time
and then some now could we go back maybe
cgi some shark activity we probably
could i guess i don't really want him to
do you want him to no no you like it old
school so keep it the way it is bruh but
you're not going to beat quinn and chief
brody right it's not happening um
i mean who ca who's going to do better
quinn let's face it so steven spielberg
jaws stood the test of time good to go
credit
however e.t bro wait why because the
story or just because especially the
whole thing the whole thing
the whole thing
it was like an okay movie but i don't
like okay movies yeah you know that
doesn't do it for me they got to blow
you away yeah i want to get i want to
get something it takes an hour and a
half to watch a movie maybe two hours
sometimes i'm not
and at this juncture in my life if
something's not good to go
i'm done no time we're not watching it
yeah i will leave a theater
i will leave i'm not watching this
stupid or you know what i'll actually do
sleep
dang straight like get some rest oh yeah
if i'm with my wife or my kids and
there's a bad movie we once saw
okay have you ever heard of a horror
movie that's called it
yeah it
yeah yeah yeah so the first one came out
my kids really liked that horror movie
my wife doesn't even watch one
millisecond of a horror movie the first
the first
the first of the new ones because it is
old school
the first of the new ones
dude with the clown face and uh yeah
that's all the print and penny wise yeah
that's always the story okay so i
watched the one of them okay and it was
okay but then my kids were all amped
yeah and so we actually went to the
theater to go see it the second version
or whatever
chapter two
whatever
we roll in there
it is so bad
i just was like i i watched maybe seven
to 12 minutes of it maybe
maybe and i was out sleeping caught up
with something
caught up on some sleep they woke me up
i saw the last
the last seven minutes of it yeah
it was so
bad
and we all walked out of there my kids
thought it was bad too oh for real thing
okay that makes sense you ever okay this
is okay now we're kind of deviating but
i don't care you talk about it it's cool
i've never seen the new ones i saw the
old ones like they're super long too
and cool i get what they're doing and
they're good but it
the new
not chapter two like the first one of
the new ones
so the thing i didn't see any of them
but they have a trailer for that oh man
it's a really good trailer there you
have a few of them but it's the one
where it's like hey um
there's georgie and then the older
brother i forget the older people i was
sleeping and
he's like hey you'll float too like hey
if you come down here
or everything floats down here that's
what the ghost kid says right everything
floats down there i think that's what
the clown said first i guess anyway so
he's like if you come down here you'll
float too
and then like this beat this horror kind
of beat and like starts speaking up and
he goes you'll float too yo float it's
really really well done trailer on that
one yep well it must have been better
than the movie i think so and remember a
long time when we were talking you're
like oh why did you start video or
whatever and the whole phenomenon that
some some movies actually a lot of
movies i mean i could name a lot of
movies that the trailer is better than
the movies like watching the trailer
provides a better like experience than
watching the movie yeah that's totally
true so that phenomenon is kind of what
made me like want to do videos or
whatever yeah it
that's one of them you have to say the t
distinctly
yes
so final spin we don't really know what
it is but it will withdraw some emotions
some lessons learned some
thought-provoking material yeah
final spin
cool
you can pre-order it now
that way you can get the first to dish
it's going to be kind of rad to have the
first dish of that i think it's gonna be
extra
cool
so check that out leadership strategy
and tactics field manual
the answer to all your questions is
actually in that book
leadership
questions the answers are there the code
the evaluation the protocols discipline
equals freedom field manual
way of the warrior kid one two three and
four mikey and the dragons about faced
by hackworth which i wrote the forward
to extreme ownership and the dichotomy
of leadership i got echelon front which
is a leadership consultancy and what we
do is solve problems through leadership
go to ashlandfront.com for details this
is where you can find details for our
live events we have the muster we have
field training exercises we have ef
battlefield the next muster is in las
vegas
october 28th and 29th
the next ftx is in september
it's september 20th and 21st it's
actually sold out so
yeah we sell things out if you want to
come then go to echelonfront.com and
click on events and you can find all
this stuff
we also have online training the extreme
ownership academy
leadership is
a skill that you need to practice it's a
perishable skill
you don't you don't take one jiu-jitsu
class now you can kick people's asses
yeah you don't take one leadership book
read it and now you're good to go no you
actually have to train
that's why we made extreme ownership
academy online leadership courses it's a
leadership gym for you to go through
we have live sessions i'm on out there
all the time answering questions
go to
extremeownership.com for that
also if you want to help service members
active and retired their families gold
star families check out mark lee's mom
mama lee she's got a charity
organization
go to america's
mightywarriors.org if you want to donate
or you want to get involved and if you
want more of my
anti-climactic anecdotes
or you need more of ekko's yattering
yarns
you can find us on the interwebs on
twitter
on the gram
and on that facebook echo's adequate
charles i'm at jockowink and again
general don bolduck can be found on
facebook twitter and instagram at
gen gen don d-o-n baldur b-o-l
so if you want to check out what he's up
to or you want to support his campaign
you can also go to don
bullduck.com d-o-n-b-o-l-d-u-c
dot com and thanks once again to general
bulldog for joining us today
and for being out there
from the beginning holding the line to
protect our way of life and the same
goes to the rest of our service men and
women out there right now also holding
the line to protect our way of life and
the same goes
to the police law enforcement
firefighters paramedics emts dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
secret service and all first responders
thank you for holding the line here at
home to keep us safe and everyone else
out there
on september 10 2001 we were at peace
the next day
september 11 2001 we were at war in one
day
everything changed
and that's the way life can be too
things change things happen people get
sick people get hurt we lose our jobs we
lose our loved ones anything and
everything can change in one day and
when it does
don't get caught back on your heels
instead go forward
go on the attack
and continue to fight
until there's peace again
and until next time zekko and jocko